an
Ooo, es ist so wichtig, dass du hernach come und herwrelst.
Wir müssen es nichtklich so einfach umsetzen, sonst handeln keine Kurse aus.
coastline,
Ja, auf gehts!
Okay, wait. Es wird die Emotes skalieren.
So, exzellente Größe. Genau, so groß muss das sein.
So, jetzt gehts hier los. Hier der Brezelsnagger. Fünf Monate. Dankeschön.
Wen haben wir denn? Rezied. Rezied. Auch zehn Monate.
Das ist ja schon, zusammengenommen ist das ja schon.
Hyper-Subscrib-Subscriptions hier.
Mock.
Moment, jetzt gibt es schon eine Ankündigung für den Scamtrain.
Sehe ich das richtig? Ja, das ist doch, das ist doch noch nicht,
noch nicht lang so. Vorher war einfach der Scamtrain am Starten.
Jetzt gibt es schon eine Ankündigung für den Scamtrain.
Twitch, Twitch weiß, wie man es macht.
YouTube hat übrigens ein neues Feature.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon gesehen habt.
Ich wollte gucken, ob das nur geht, wenn man eingeloggt ist.
Wartet mal. YouTube hat ein neues, ja das, ne, guck mal hier.
Wobei doch, das geht nur, wenn man eingeloggt ist.
Wenn man eingeloggt ist, gibt es dann, gibt es dann New for You,
gibt es da jetzt hier einen Button, irgendwo.
Und ich habe das letztes Mal ausprobiert auf, auf der Smartphone-App.
Da wurden mir richtig viel Schwachsinn vorgeschlagen, ja.
Die schönsten Bahnstrecken in Deutschland und solche Dinger.
Hä? Warum ist das New for You?
Ich habe nicht ein Video in der Richtung bisher auf YouTube geguckt.
Aber gut, wenn YouTube das meint, dann sollte ich das mal aus,
dann sollte ich das ja mal.
YouTube weiß es ja in der Regel besser als man selbst.
Shorts, ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich finde Shorts gar nicht so doof.
Ich gucke, ich gucke manchmal abends, wenn ich im Bett lege,
das ist vor dem Smartphone in der Hand, da gucke ich noch ein paar,
noch ein paar Shorts. Wobei ich ja ehrlich sagen muss,
ich finde so den Versuch von YouTube, ich meine,
das ist ja eindeutig der Versuch von YouTube,
ein bisschen TikTok-User abzugraben, das sieht man auch da.
Dass ganz viele Videos einfach Reuploads von TikTok sind.
Habt ihr euch das mal aufgefallen, wie viele YouTube-Shorts
einfach das TikTok, sogar das TikTok-Logo noch drin haben?
Ah, so was, okay.
Ja, es gibt ganz viele YouTube-Shorts,
die haben noch das TikTok-Logo drin.
Also die Leute sind nicht sonderlich kreativ, was das angeht.
YouTube hat ja versucht, alles irgendwie nachzumachen.
Die haben Shorts, dann hatten sie ihre komischen Stories.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt jemand benutzt.
Wo sie irgendwie Instagram-Zeug nachmachen wollten.
Dann haben sie YouTube-Gaming.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was kein Mensch wirklich verwendet,
glaube ich. Das ist bestimmt, da ist wahrscheinlich
Facebook-Gaming noch beliebter.
Wobei YouTube macht es einfach mit der Masse der Views.
Clips haben sie jetzt auch.
GeneralSlaying, danke schön für 11 Monate,
14 Monate Alper-Subscriptions. Stimmt, Clips gibt es jetzt auch noch.
Du kannst ja auf YouTube theoretisch auch subscriben.
Du kannst ja theoretisch auf YouTube auch subscriben.
Das heißt dann Channel-Membership, glaube ich.
Da gibt es dann auch Emotes und sowas.
Das macht bloß kaum einer auf YouTube.
Ich habe mir auch überlegt, ob ich das anschalten soll.
Aber YouTube hat ja so komische Vorgaben, so nach dem Motto
lade ein Willkommens-Video an deine Fans hoch oder so.
Die wollen von mir, dass ich quasi so ein Video mache wie früher.
Weiß ich, ob das auch einer kennt.
Die gibt es heute ja bestimmt immer noch in Massen.
Diese Her-Tutorial-Videos, so nach dem Motto
meine Gott, meine Community, ihr seid die Besten auf der Welt.
Ich bin euch so dankbar.
Ich wäre nichts ohne meine Community.
Das ist so emotional.
Leute, ich bin euch so unglaublich dankbar.
Ich weiß noch, wie ich früher den Müll am Hauptbahnhof fressen musste.
Und heute kann ich mit dem 5-Steine-Restaurant in Dubai sitzen.
Ich bin euch so dankbar, Leute.
Die Sorte von Videos möchte YouTube, dass man die irgendwie macht.
It's easy mitgeschnitten.
Ey, das wäre eigentlich geil.
Das wäre eigentlich die komplette Verarschung von diesem...
Von diesem...
Das müsste man echt klippen.
Ich lade das einfach als Willkommens-Video hoch
für YouTube-Channel-Memberchips.
Max zieht nach Dubai.
Ich will nicht nach Dubai.
Soll ich in Dubai?
In Dubai, reden die Arabisch?
Weiß nicht, was sie da... Was reden die in Dubai?
Da kann ich meine Call of Duty 4...
Wie hieß diese Fraktion in Call of Duty 4?
Die Terroristen-Fraktion aus Call of Duty 4.
Kann ich meine Call of Duty 4 Arabisch-Kenntnisse verwenden?
Ja, siehst du...
Dubai, Dubai ist...
Tango Sucker.
Was übrigens gar nicht Tango Sucker heißt,
sondern das ist tatsächlich...
Irgendetwas hab ich mal gelesen im Call of Duty-Wiki.
Das ist tatsächlich irgendein arabisches Wort,
was sich anhört wie Tango Sucker.
Es bedeutet irgendwas ganz was anderes.
Keine Ahnung.
Bambi.
Aber, nee, nee, nee, nach Dubai, nach Dubai
will ich im Leben nicht ziehen.
Was will man in Dubai eigentlich?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Es läuft mit... Gut, wenig Steuern bezahlen wahrscheinlich.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, du hast den Anfang nicht mitgekriegt.
Max, was sagst du jetzt nachdem NRW los ist?
Ich meine, viel Wasser ist los.
Ich bin froh, dass bei uns nicht so ist.
Das klingt jetzt immer fies, ne?
Wenn man sagt so nach dem Motto, ich bin ja froh,
dass bei uns nicht so ist, aber ich bin erst mal froh,
dass es bei mir nicht so ist.
Natürlich ist es scheiße für die Leute, die es betrifft.
Das ist klar.
Aber ich bin erst mal froh, dass mein Keller trocken ist.
Und meine Straße, die Autos noch auf der Straße stehen.
Das ist meine Straße.
Meine persönliche Straße, ja.
GitHub Copilot...
Ich finde, es ist eine gute Idee,
die aktuell aber noch nicht allzu viel bringt.
Also, wir sehen ja jetzt schon
Stack Overflow Driven Programming von Leuten,
die den ganzen Tag Copy und Paste von Stack Overflow machen.
Wir werden sicherlich in nächster Zeit auch
GitHub Copilot Driven Programming sehen.
Aber das stelle ich mir noch nicht so geil vor, ja.
Ja, das können die generell in den Ländern da ganz gut.
Echt, muss man da gar keine Steuern bezahlen?
Hey, dann wäre es doch vielleicht eine Idee,
nach Dubai zu gehen, aber so einfach ist es nicht.
Ich habe letztens ein Video geguckt,
dass das mit dem Steuern...
Nein, mache ich nicht.
Ich fahre in Opel Agila in grün.
2001 oder so, oder A heißt das Ding?
So, genau so ein, genau so ein.
GG.
GG Eats habe ich als Nummernschild, aber...
GG Eats, 420.
Agile, damals hat noch keiner dran gedacht,
dass Agile Geschichten so werden.
Ich habe übrigens letztens ein Video geguckt,
so einfach ist das gar nicht mit...
Leute, der Scam Train ist vorbei.
Wir haben uns nicht scammeln lassen,
es ist ein Schlecht-Excel.
Wobei, was heißt habt ihr gut gemacht?
Ich brauche ja Easy-Money-Subs.
Nein, das ist gar nicht gut.
Oh, jetzt habe ich eine Woche nicht geschrieben,
die richtig hart gedroppt, die Subzahlen.
MonkaS, Aox, danke für den Prime-Sub.
Ja, jetzt geht es aufwärts.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen?
Ich habe letztens ein Video zugesehen,
das ist nicht so einfach.
Erstens musst du mal 5 Jahre,
du darfst dich nicht länger als ein halbes Jahr
in Deutschland aufhalten.
Du darfst ja auch keine Wohnung besitzen.
Du darfst auch nicht länger als ein halbes Jahr da sein.
Und wenn du Pech hast, musst du sogar noch
Steuern bezahlen, wenn du wegziehst.
Das ist tatsächlich nicht so einfach,
wie das auf den ersten Blick aussieht,
so nach dem Motto, man zieht nach Dubai
und bezahlt keine Steuern.
Ich würde auch nicht nach Dubai ziehen,
ich würde auch nicht in ein anderes Land ziehen,
wo Steuern niedriger sind.
Auch wenn es mir auf den Sack geht,
dass ich so viel Steuern bezahlen muss,
aber im Prinzip finde ich es hier doch ganz okay.
Gut, das wundert mich nicht.
Sie haben sich ja auch wieder genau
die richtigen Leute angezogen.
Simon Desi und irgendwelche Beauty-Mädels.
Also das seriöseste vom seriösesten
haben sie sich angezogen.
Das passt irgendwie auch dazu.
Gangsofanao, genau.
Drei Tage kein Internet.
Was ich so gesehen habe,
an gibt es da genug Videos von und Berichte,
dass da kein Internet wohl das kleinste Problem
war, dass da auch teilweise ein paar Tage lang
der Strom nicht ging und so was.
Das ist eigentlich so was,
wo man gar nicht von ausgeht,
dass wir das in Deutschland haben,
wo man eigentlich überhaupt nicht mit rechnet.
Hat man ja auch nicht gerechnet.
Aber jetzt ist es halt da.
Und was man daran sieht ist,
wie wenig es eigentlich nur bedarf,
um das tägliche Leben, was man kennt,
so komplett aus der Bahn zu werfen.
Das muss einem klar sein.
Man fühlt sich hier immer so nach dem Motto,
Alter, easy, kann einem alles gar nichts passieren.
Aber das kann mal ganz schnell gehen.
Man kann sich sogar ein Impressum erstellen lassen
mit GitHub, Copilot.
Das stelle ich mir schwierig vor.
Das ist das Besten, was man bei mir reinschreiben muss.
Dann haben die alle diese Standard Akme.
Lorem Ipsum Impressum.
Richtig, Agile.
Wobei man sagen muss,
dass die in Saudi-Arabien und Dubai,
die sind nicht blöd.
Also gerade den ist ja auch klar.
Also gerade in Saudi-Arabien
habe ich letztens erst wieder was drüber gelesen,
über den Prinz, über den Prinz.
Und zwar, das ist schon ein bisschen her.
Die haben ja auch so ein bisschen Bedenken,
dass die in nächsten Jahrzehnten
öltechnisch jetzt nicht mehr easy money bekommen.
Und die sind da richtig am Vorausdenken.
Die versuchen jetzt irgendwelche Staatsforce zu gründen
und sich irgendwie ausländisch Beteiligungen zu kaufen.
Übrigens, Frauen dürfen da jetzt auch Auto fahren
in Saudi-Arabien, habe ich gelesen.
Weil Dubai wohl einen Riesen aufschreien.
Die haben sich alle gedacht,
wait, was ist da los?
Warum dürfen Frauen überhaupt das Haus verlassen?
So geht es ja nicht.
Aber anscheinend dürfen jetzt sogar Frauen Auto fahren.
Das ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Und die bereiten sich da wirklich drauf vor,
dass wenn Öl-Money mal weniger wird,
dass sie auch noch irgendwie über die Runden kommen.
Da sieht man mal, man kann auch,
man kann viel Negatives darüber sagen,
über diese Ecke der Welt.
Aber zumindest eins scheinen sie hinzukriegen,
so ein bisschen in die Zukunft zu denken.
Was ist denn in 10 Jahren?
Was ist denn in 20 Jahren?
Das ist das, wo wir uns ein bisschen schwer tun.
Ja, ist ja auch richtig so.
Ist ja auch richtig so.
Also wenn du versuchst abzuhauen,
dann musst du übrigens noch einmal ordentlich steuern.
Das finde ich auch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ja, genau.
Die haben teilweise Trinkwasser.
Klar, mit Hochwasser hast du oftmals auch Trinkwasserprobleme.
Und vor allem haben sie wohl auch Stromversorgung.
Ja, ja.
Also da geht es wohl richtig, richtig zur Sache.
Also muss ich ja mal nur die Videos von angucken.
Ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen,
da haben sie eben einen Rentner,
die Feuerwehr, einen Rentner aus dem Auto gerettet,
was auf einmal komplett unter Wasser war.
Ich meine, ein Auto,
ich meine, wie hoch ist denn so ein Auto?
Zwo, naja, gut, wenn es ein großes ist.
So 1,80 oder so.
Je nachdem, was ein fettes Auto ist
oder wenn es ein kleines ist,
so 1,60 oder so,
das ist schon ganz schön hoches Wasser bei uns.
Also für unsere Verhältnisse.
Wenn wir jetzt irgendwie,
frag mich nicht,
wo gibt es öfters mal Überschwemmungen?
So Asien oder so, da ist das wahrscheinlich nichts.
Aber für unsere Verhältnisse ist das schon echt heftig.
Was?
Oh, das klingt ja wieder richtig exquisite.
Stack, was mache ich da auf?
Ach so, das ist das.
Das ist der...
Ja, das kenne ich.
Das ist dieser Random Generator
für Firmenbeschreibung, ja.
Ja, kein Strom.
Das habe ich auch gelesen.
Ja, gut.
Erst mal ist Strand schuld,
dass zu viel geregnet hat.
Das darf man nicht außer...
Das darf man nicht außer achtmal.
Klar, natürlich, man hätte sicherlich
mit weniger Waldabholsten und sonst was
der ganze Sache ein bisschen vorbeugen können.
Aber dass jetzt mehr Regen als jemals zuvor
und alles Mögliche da überschwemmt wird,
ist halt auch das hauptsächliche Problem.
Da kannst du ja aber auch leider nichts gegen machen.
Deine Cute-VM,
das hast du doch jetzt schon fünfmal geschickt.
Das hast du auch schon fünfmal mehr angeguckt.
Ja, aber den...
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Aber den Vorwurf kann man nicht unbedingt jetzt
den direkt machen, die es gerade trifft.
Die haben halt gelitten.
Und es trifft es jetzt halt auch mal in Deutschland.
Es ist ja in vielen Teilen der Welt
klimatechnisch schon lange ein Problem.
Es gibt ja in...
Wo ist das in...
Ich glaube in Thailand?
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Ich glaube in Thailand ist das,
wo sie so einen kompletten Stadtteil
hinter einer riesen Wand haben,
die jederzeit quasi umfallen kann
und dann alle überschwemmt werden.
Ich frag mich, wie die da
noch ruhig schlafen können, wenn du da so wohnst.
Da sind wahrscheinlich die Grundstückspreise
äußerst niedrig, wenn du irgendwo hinter dieser Wand wohnst.
Und es sind nicht nur einfach nur ein paar Häuser oder so.
Da wohnen tausende Leute dahinter.
Oder zehntausende Leute.
Ist das bang? Ich guck mal, ob ich ein Bild finde.
Was heißt Damm?
Damm?
Ja, er geht genau hier irgendwie in die Richtung.
Das meine ich nicht.
Ich habe ein anderes Bild gefunden.
Aber sowas in der Richtung ist echt ein Problem.
Da wohnen zehntausende Leute quasi
unter dem Meeresspiegel und unter dem,
wo das Wasser steht.
Und wenn der Damm erst mal,
wenn der Damm da erst mal bricht,
dann ist es vorbei.
Das kriegst du ja auch so schnell nicht mehr zu.
So sieht es aus, ja.
Es wäre gut, wenn man real life Leute bannen könnte.
Ah gut, wobei eigentlich wäre es nicht gut,
wenn man real life Leute bannen könnte,
weil dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich
90% der Menschheit gebannt.
RobDead, Dankeschön für den Sub.
BigBrain, 2 Subscriptions.
Nein, 1 Sub, aber was weiß ich.
Massive Subscriptions hier wieder.
Jetzt geht es aufwärts.
Kappa kommt, das ist auch ein guter Name.
Das Remake ist dann Kappa HD.
Kommen.
Cool Streamer gebannt, was?
Ja, das habe ich mitgekriegt.
Sind die eigentlich wieder da mittlerweile?
Ich habe mitbekommen,
dass in letzter Zeit ein paar
Hottube und sowas Mädels gebannt wurden.
Und dann haben sie sich
mitgekriegt.
mitgekriegt und sowas Mädels gebannt wurden.
Und die waren diesmal erstaunlich,
erstaunlich ruhig auf Social Media.
Weiß ich nicht,
hat es jemand mitbekommen,
sind die wieder da?
Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich sind die wieder da.
Man bringt Kohle, warum?
Nein, aber ich sollte.
Ich habe zu viel Geld rumliegen,
was immer weniger wird.
Eigentlich müsste ich mich endlich mal
entweder selbst damit beschäftigen
oder sich damit beschäftigen lassen.
Zu Hot Tubes.
Nee, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Meinung dazu.
Was ist das?
Battlefield looks like trash.
Das können wir uns angucken.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Da bin ich.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt
gleich mal an.
Wir gucken uns an, ob das.
Vielleicht ist es auch ein Troll-Video.
Kann ja auch sein.
Es kann ja auch ein Troll-Video sein,
der einfach nur die Fanboys
triggern will.
Was sogar gut möglich ist,
ehrlich gesagt, auf YouTube.
Weil auf YouTube sind so unglaublich
viele dummen Leute,
die es nicht checken,
wenn einer trollt.
Es ist der Wahnsinn.
Also ich glaube,
lass mal überlegen,
lass mal kurz in mich gehen.
Welche so Mainstream-Plattform
hat die größte Idioten-Konzentration?
Oder was heißt Konzentration?
Ja doch, die meisten Leute
sind den höchsten Anteil an Deppen.
Nee, Facebook nicht.
Ich glaube nicht Facebook.
Facebook, die sind einfach nur alt.
TikTok.
Ich weiß nicht.
Nee, Twitter nicht.
Twitter sind die Leute nicht doof.
Auf Twitter sind die Leute nur,
wie soll man sagen,
recht gefangen,
recht gefangen in ihrer Weltanschauung.
Sagen wir mal so.
Auf Twitter gilt genau eine Sache.
Und wenn die nicht dem entspricht,
was der jeweilige Twitter-Benutzer
ihm gefällt,
wird halt geflamed oder, oder,
ja,
Twitter-User,
ich würde sogar so weit gehen.
Genau, das ist richtig.
Auf Twitter sind die Leute
einfach nur schnell getriggert.
Gute Frage.
Okay, gute Frage ist tatsächlich
ganz weit vorne.
Ich glaube,
ich würde sogar so weit gehen
und sagen von allen
Social-Media-Plattformen.
Ja gut, Reddit,
Reddit lassen wir mal außen vor.
Aber von allen Social-Media-Plattformen,
wenn du sowas nimmst wie
Twitter, Facebook, Instagram,
TikTok, was auch immer,
da sind auf Twitter,
würde ich sagen,
potenziell noch die schlauesten Leute,
aber auch die festgefahrensten Leute.
Aber ja,
die höchste Idiotenkonzentration,
es könnte tatsächlich sein,
dass es auf Facebook ist.
Zumindest,
worauf ich raus will,
es gibt viele dummen Leute auf YouTube.
Da sieht man auch,
da sieht man auch
an dem ganzen Content.
Ich meine, du musst nur
den Content aufmachen,
der in Trends ist.
Dann weißt du klar,
an wen sich das richtet.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
wie komme ich überhaupt auf Trends?
Wo sind denn die aktuellen Trends?
Hier, Explore?
Trending.
Na gut,
aktuell trendet Hochwasser,
das wundert mich nicht.
Aber du musst dir nur
die Trends angucken in Deutschland,
da weißt du schon, ob es scheit.
Facebook ist Megaboomer-Plattform.
So könnte man das auch sagen.
Nutzt eigentlich noch jemand
Tumblr?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich glaube,
ich war seit 3 oder 4 Jahren
nicht mehr auf Tumblr.
Tumblr haben,
das ist auch,
das ist wieder so ein typisches Beispiel,
wenn so Corporations
das eigentliche Produkt nicht verstehen.
Tumblr war ja so eine Blogging-Plattform.
Und man muss ehrlich sagen,
man muss ehrlich sagen,
es war zwar eine Blogging-Plattform
für alle Themen.
Und da gab es auch relativ viele
große und ganz gute Blogs
für alle Themen.
Aber ein nicht unerheblicher Teil
von Tumblr war halt
eher in die Richtung.
Man muss sagen,
Tumblr war das Only-Fans
der damaligen Zeit
nur kostenlos.
Also auf Tumblr gab es
gab es viele Blogs
in recht eindeutiger Richtung.
Nur, dass es noch nicht mal
was gekostet hat.
Nein, Tumblr war neuer als Facebook.
Aber die haben es verkackt.
Die haben es verkackt.
Yahoo hat das irgendwann gekauft.
Tumblr.
Und die haben dann gesagt,
wir bannen jeglichen Porn
und sonstige Sachen
und haben dann komische Entscheidungen getroffen
und schon war Tumblr weg vom Fenster.
Ich glaube innerhalb von 2 Jahren
war Tumblr weg vom Fenster.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie sehr man das so verkacken kann.
Ja, also Reddit muss man sagen.
Die Leute auf Reddit sind nicht doof.
Auf Reddit gibt es nur eine Krankheit,
die im Internet viele haben,
aber auf Reddit ganz extrem.
Also Reddit, du kannst im Prinzip,
wenn du wirklich was wissen willst,
also wenn du wirklich die Wahrheit,
sagen wir mal,
wenn du wirklich die Wahrheit
zu einer Sache im Internet erfahren willst,
dann darfst du nicht auf Reddit gehen
oder irgendeine Social Media Plattform
und darfst fragen,
Leute, wie ist das eigentlich?
Sondern du musst auf diese Plattform gehen
und sagen, Leute, ich weiß, wie es ist.
So und so sieht es aus.
Weil dann kannst du sicher sein,
es werden sich 5000 Leute melden,
die dir erst mal erklären,
du liegst komplett falsch
und hast keine Ahnung.
Also der eigentliche Trick,
um auf Reddit sinnvoll Antworten zu bekommen,
ist nicht zu fragen,
sondern irgendeine Aussage zu machen,
die nicht stimmt.
Und dann springen alle drauf
und du landest auf der Startseite
und weißt danach Bescheid.
Gut, du kannst dir vielleicht
einen neuen Twitter-Account machen danach.
Ist vielleicht nicht verkehrt,
aber ja, also dass das funktioniert.
Reddit ist echt nicht schlecht.
Reddit ist ein bisschen,
jetzt übertrieben gesagt,
Reddit ist so das Mainstream 4Chan
oder so das Mainstream Forum
mit aber auch genug Nischenseiten,
die vielleicht nicht ganz so abgedreht sind,
aber irgendwie für jeden was dabei.
Leider, leider ist das Reddit-UI absolut eklig
und Old Reddit ist auch schon
echt in die Jahre gekommen.
Und wisst ihr, was mich an Reddit
am meisten nervt,
ist dieser App-Zwang.
Du machst Google-Suche,
findest einen Reddit-Post,
du machst den auf
und du kannst den nicht mal aufmachen,
weil irgendein dummes Pop-Up auf iOS kommt.
Ha, lesen sie jetzt,
ist noch viel besser in der App.
Ich will es nicht besser in der App lesen,
ich will es erst mal überhaupt im Browser lesen.
Also Reddit-App ist wirklich,
das ist abartig nervig.
Deswegen mache ich es jetzt folgendermaßen,
ich verwende keine Reddit-App,
ich verwende eine Third-Party-Reddit-App
und da hat Reddit einfach gelitten.
Ach ja, und das Streaming-Feature von Reddit
verstehe ich nicht.
Manchmal gehst du auf Reddit
und bekommst einen Videostream vorgeschlagen,
wo Leute ihre Haustiere filmen und sowas.
Das Video-Streaming-Feature von Reddit
habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden.
Das meiste,
das meiste stimmt nicht,
aber bestimmt zu 20% oder so.
Es ist generell ein Problem von Foren,
dass Foren selten hilfreich sind,
deswegen beteilige ich mich auch.
Also früher war ich in total vielen Foren,
sei es irgendein Counter-Strike-Forum,
sei es irgendein Gaming-Forum,
ich war total viel in Foren.
Ich war sogar früher,
jetzt kommt Boomer-Time,
ich habe sogar ganz früher
in manchen News-Groups gepostet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob überhaupt noch
irgendjemand News-Groups kennt.
Da war ich aber selbst noch jung,
das war eigentlich auch fast nicht meine Zeit, Alter.
News-Groups.
Heute benutzen die Leute News-Groups
nur noch, um Porn-Down zu lollen, glaube ich.
Aber das ist ein generelles Problem von Foren,
dass die Antworten zu 90% nicht hilfreich und scheiße sind.
Deswegen waren ja auch,
also der hauptsächliche Grund,
warum Stack Overflow und Stack Exchange
und sowas so erfolgreich ist,
ist, weil das Foren-Konzept scheiße ist.
Und die haben das,
also Stack Overflow hat ja im Prinzip
das Foren-Konzept genommen,
nur haben sie einen Rating eingeführt
für hilfreiche Antworten,
also dass hilfreiche Antworten belohnt werden
und nicht hilfreiche Diskussionen
erst gar nicht stattfinden.
Das ist ja das eigentliche Geheimnis
von Stack Overflow
und diesen ganzen Fragen-Antwortseiten.
Du belohnst die Leute für gute Antworten.
Das ist das, was in einem Forum nicht passiert ist.
Und Foren ist halt oftmals das Problem.
Irgendjemand, meistens noch eine Neuning,
weil warum sollst du sonst was fragen,
geht in ein Forum
und stellt eine Einsteigerfrage,
was ja vollkommen okay ist.
Dafür ist ein Forum.
Und der wird zugetextet
mit einem Bullshit.
Das ist absolut der Wahnsinn.
Also eines der schlimmsten Foren auf dieser Welt,
auf Deutsch,
ich bin nicht aktiv,
aber ich stolper dabei Google-Suchen manchmal drüber.
Eines der schlimmsten Foren auf Deutsch ist
das Microcontroller Forum.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das so schreibt.
Ich glaube, das da.
Dieses hässliche Ding.
Das ist so dermaßen ätzend, Alter.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Was da für Vollspasten rumlaufen.
Das kann man echt nicht anders ausdrücken.
Da sind auch hilfreiche Antworten dabei.
Aber es ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Da kommt irgendein Neuling hin
und sagt, keine Ahnung,
er hat sich irgendein Arduino gekauft,
möchte jetzt eine LED blinken lassen
und postet seinen Code.
Der ist 5 Zeilen lang und hat irgendwo
einen ganz easy Fehler.
Also was man auf den ersten Blick sehen könnte.
Dann kommt der erste,
bei uns werden Codeblocks nicht so formatiert.
Dann formatiert es der Neuling richtig,
sein Codeblock.
Entweder ist direkt nachdem er seinen Codeblock formatiert hat
und es keine Kritik mehr an diesem Post gibt,
ist die Diskussion beendet
und nie wieder antwortet irgendjemand auf die Frage von ihm.
Oder es findet noch irgendwie einer was.
Und er sagt dann nach dem Motto,
dann kommt der nächste an und sagt,
das ist aber nicht schöner C++-Style.
Dann kommt der nächste als Antwort drauf,
ja C ist ja auch das einzig wahre.
Dann kommt der dritte,
die diskutieren dann 20 Seiten drüber,
dass er jetzt irgendwie die Eindrückung falsch hat.
Anstatt dem armen Kerl mal zu helfen,
dass er einfach nur irgendwie
True mit False verwechselt hat
bei Output anschalten.
Also das Mikrocontroller Forum
ist eines der schlimmsten
und beschissensten Foren,
die ich je gesehen habe.
Und ich bin da selbst nicht aktiv, muss ich sagen.
Ich sehe das nur, weil ich Google-Ergebnisse finde
und das oftmals auf dieses Forum verweist,
wenn man so nach Elektronik sagt,
aber da stehen nie, nie,
vielleicht in 5% der Fälle,
wenn man Glück hat,
irgendwie auch nur was ansatzweise Hilfreiches drin.
Es wird sich eher darüber diskutiert,
wer jetzt dem anderen möglichst gut belegen kann,
dass er keine Ahnung hat.
Im Prinzip, die Antworten in diesem Forum
drehen sich nur darum,
dass man den anderen permanent erklärt,
dass sie keine Ahnung haben.
Ja, und dann kommen noch die üblichen Fragen genau.
Wenn einer fragt, wie kann man das machen,
da kommt als Antwort,
warum will man das denn so machen,
so kann man das doch gar nicht machen.
Deswegen sind Foren auch gescheitert.
Ich mag das neue Reddit UI nicht.
Guck mal.
Zum Beispiel, gehen wir mal in das aktuelle C-Sharp,
Subreddit rein.
Allein schon das hier finde ich eklig.
Das musste immer umstelle.
Das musste immer schon mal umstellen,
weil ansonsten ist von der Seite ja kaum was übrig.
Aber das ist die Fault.
Ich meine, warum ist das überhaupt so?
Mich juckt dieser Shit hier an der Seite überhaupt nicht.
Da war OldReddit,
weil OldReddit ist hässlich wie die Nacht,
aber zumindest OldReddit hatte den Vorteil,
dass du wenigstens noch was gesehen hast.
Du bist reingezoomt.
Ich will ja auch was sehen.
Guck mal, guck mal.
Wenn ich das so mache, erkennst du doch gar nichts mehr.
Ich muss da schon ein bisschen reinzoomen,
dass das ordentlich funktioniert.
Also das ist das erste,
was beim neuen Reddit sagt, warum ist hier so viel Platz.
Und dann, was auch total eklig ist,
und was gerade auf dem Smartphone eklig ist,
wenn du das hier anklickst,
auf dem Smartphone ist es so,
ach nee, ist hier auch so.
Du bekommst einen Popup.
Und wenn du irgendwo anders hinklickst,
oder die Seite zu langsam lädt, und du willst scrollen,
dann geht das direkt wieder zu und solche Dinge.
Irgendwie sieht das Font-Rendering heute mega kaputt aus.
Was ist denn da im Arsch?
Normalerweise liegt das an meinem Browser.
Ich hab eben gerade ein Browser-Update installiert.
Ist das broken, das Font-Rendering gerade?
Ja, sieht so aus.
Im Chromium ist das Font-Rendering voll im Arsch.
Sehr gut.
Und dazu kommt,
dass du ja mittlerweile nicht einfach mehr
eine komplette Diskussion richtig ausklappen kannst.
Du hast permanent solche Dinge,
was nicht richtig lädt.
Guck mal, das geht eigentlich noch weiter.
Und dann sagst du, view all comments.
Ich mein, dieses Ding,
dieses Reddit,
dieser Thread hat acht
comments, acht.
Wozu brauche ich da
irgendeine komische
Anzeige mit
weiter gehts hier
Das sind acht posts.
Ich kann acht posts einfach untereinander
laden und gut ist.
Also ich kann
new reddit
echt nur sehr schwer
benutzen. Für mich ein gutes
Beispiel für
Übersichtlichkeit
ist das hier. Ihr werdet jetzt sagen, das ist mega
hässlich.
Ihr werdet jetzt sagen, das ist mega hässlich.
Aber
das ist zumindest
von der Übersichtlichkeit her
noch okay.
Und wenn du hier Threads hast mit vielen comments,
dann kannst du einfach durchscrollen und gut ist.
Das ist jetzt nicht schön,
aber
es funktioniert, so wie das Internet
gedacht ist.
Ja, manchmal fände ich es tatsächlich ganz cool,
wenn sie hier noch einen Vorschau sammeln hätten.
Übrigens dieses Ding,
diese, wie spricht man das überhaupt?
Y Combinator Hacker News.
Das ist das Ding, was ihr lesen
müsst, wenn ihr auch mal in den
Kommentaren jemanden antreffen
wollt, der damit was zu tun hat.
Also, mal
angenommen, es gibt irgendeinen Bug in Chrome.
Und jede Newsseite
berichtet darüber. Da könnt ihr sicher sein, Google
Mitarbeiter werden nicht irgendwie bei
PC Welt in die News gucken. Aber
wenn es einen Hacker
News Thread gibt, ist die Chance,
dass ihr ein paar Google Mitarbeiter in den
Kommentaren findet, die damit was zu
tun haben oder zumindest ein bisschen Ahnung davon
haben, gar nicht so
schlecht.
Also, das ist wirklich die beste
Quelle für solche Sachen.
Oder eine ziemlich gute Quelle.
Leider haben die auch so ein bisschen
dieses Forums
gehen, das über unsinnige
Sachen ewig lang
diskutiert wird.
Und wo die hier richtig gut sind,
wo die hier richtig gut sind,
ist Rust anzupreisen.
Also, wenn irgendwo mal wieder kommt,
Buffer, Overflow,
C++, Scheiße gebaut,
dann kommen erstmal 50 Leute an.
Mit Rust wäre das nicht passiert.
Hier ist übrigens der Link zur letzten Rust-Version.
Das können die hier wirklich gut.
Ja, das habe ich übrigens, benutze
ich, benutze ich. Apollo auf
iOS, besser.
Reddit-Reader.
Ja, das wäre wirklich nice.
Gute Frage
ist,
Gute Frage ist, glaube ich,
eines der schlechtesten Seiten aller Zeiten.
Vor allem, was
auch immer auf gute Frage, was ich
da nicht verstehe, ist,
da postet irgendjemand, keine Ahnung,
wie fange ich
am besten an mit Bilder malen?
Also, keine Ahnung,
irgendeine Frage auf gute Frage. Und die Antwort,
die dann kommt, ist, hm, weiß ich
nicht, müsste ich mir mal Gedanken zumachen,
oder sowas. Das ist dann eine Antwort,
das geht dann als Antwort durch die Antwort, das weiß ich
nicht. Also, gute
Frage ist wirklich Müll.
Wikihau, ja, Wikihau ist auch so ein Ding.
Stack-Overflow ist
das Beste.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Genau. Am besten
sind so diese, das wurde schon fünfmal
beantwortet, aber er ist nicht in der Lage, die
Antwort zu finden, die es in diesem Fall gar
nicht gibt.
Oder nicht, passt.
Die Seite ist hässlich, das stimmt,
aber die hat gutes Essen.
Die haben gutes Essen.
Hier.
Aber die Seite ist hässlich.
Steam-Diskussion, das kommt auf
das Spiel an und das kommt darauf an, ob
der Hersteller sich für Steam-Diskussion
interessiert oder nicht.
Microsoft, ja gut, Microsoft-Forum
oder dieses MSDN-Forum kannst du eh
komplett vergessen. Also, das ist
eh der Wahnsinn. Da hab ich letztens auch wieder
irgendwas gefunden.
Lass mal überlegen,
was war denn das?
Windows-Fehler
war das.
Ich hab
irgendeinen Windows-Fehler bekommen.
Irgendeine Generic-Windows-Fehler-
Meldung.
Und da hab ich danach gesucht.
Dann hab ich den ersten Eintrag gefunden
im Microsoft-Forum, wo genau einer das
gleiche Problem hatte. Und dann hat irgendein
so ein Microsoft-Support-Inner
nicht abwertend gemeint.
In dem Fall, das war wirklich, zumindest
vom Namen her, las sich das äußerst indisch.
Und ist ja auch bekannt für, dass Microsoft
da viele Support-Leute hat.
Also der Microsoft-Support-Inner hat dann
irgendwie drauf geantwortet.
Das ist ein Fehler, der
da und damit zusammen, also im Prinzip
hat er einfach nur das, was in der Fehlermeldung
schon da war, nochmal geschrieben
und hat danach irgendwie
fünf Seiten Troubleshooting gepostet.
Von Systemwiderherstellungspunkt
bis zu, ähm,
frag mich nicht, bis zu Festplatte
defragmentieren. Komplett umsonst.
Und danach die übliche Frage,
wenn dieses Problem gelöst ist, bitte diesen Post
als gelöst markieren. Ich glaub,
dieses Microsoft-Support-Forum
hat eines der schlechtesten
Fragen zu Lösungsraten
auf dem Planeten.
Und was übrigens,
ich kann euch eine schöne Story von der Arbeit erzählen,
Microsoft Support.
Wir hatten das Problem,
dass, oder wir haben das Problem,
dass Azure Files, ich weiß,
hat jemand von euch schon mal Azure Files verwendet
über NFS?
Also da kann man Dateien in Azure ablegen und die sich dann
auf seinen VMs mounten
über NFS oder Samba, also über
Windows-Freigabe oder NFS.
Stellt euch NFS einfach als
Linux-mäßige Dateifreigabe
vor.
So, das kann man sich mounten und wir haben
festgestellt, dass es mega,
mega, mega langsam ist.
Ihr müsst euch vorstellen,
tausend Dateien zu erstellen
über NFS auf Azure Files
dauert, ratet mal, chat,
ratet mal.
Tausend Dateien anlegen.
Leere Dateien, wie lange dauert das über
Azure Files NFS?
Oder generell über Azure Files?
Zwei Tage,
zehn Minuten, fünf Minuten, zwanzig Minuten,
ne, ne, ne, so lange.
Nein, tausend Dateien sind ja nichts.
Also ich sag mal, ByteStrike sagt fünf
Millisekunden, ja das ist ungefähr,
was es lokal vielleicht braucht, ja.
Nein,
13 Sekunden.
Das schwankt,
13 bis 20 Sekunden.
Für tausend Dateien.
Wenn ich lokal tausend Dateien anlege,
dauert das zehn Millisekunden.
Das ist
tausend Dateien, leere Dateien, einfach
anlegen.
13 bis 20 Sekunden.
Das ist
der Witz.
13 bis 20 Sekunden,
stell euch das mal vor, ihr legt eine Datei an
und wartet einfach, ihr könnt quasi
wirklich nach dem Enter drücken,
beim Dateianlegen noch zugucken,
gefühlt wieder die Datei anlegen.
So, und zumindest
haben wir dann bei Microsoft
so ein Support-Ticket
oder was auch immer aufgemacht.
Azure Files NFS ist fucking
lahm. Was ist denn da los?
Und Microsoft hat als Antwort gepostet.
Also sie haben, als Antwort
haben die geschrieben, oh dieser
Fehl, es ist irgendwie so nach dem, oh hier, super,
super, danke für die Meldung
und wir haben das Ganze jetzt
nachgestellt und was sie nachgestellt
haben ist, er hat irgendwie fünf Seiten
Antwort gepostet, indem er genau
das Gleiche geschrieben hat, was wir auch schon
geschrieben haben, nur in anderen Worten.
Er hat quasi geschrieben, es ist langsam
und er hat das jetzt
gemessen, es ist langsam
und bei seinen Messungen ist es rausgekommen,
dass es langsam ist und wenn er das
mit weniger Dateien macht, ist es auch langsam
und wenn er das mit mehr Dateien macht, ist es
auch langsam und das Anlegen
dauert, ist langsam
und das Löschen ist langsam und das
Erstellen ist auch langsam. Also der hat im Prinzip
das Gleiche, was wir schon geschrieben
haben, als eigentliche Support-Anfrage,
hat er nochmal über wirklich ewig
langen Support-Antwort-Post
hingeschrieben. Das ist übrigens der
Titel von dem Typ, war auch geil.
Das ist der
Senior
Senior Support
Escalation Officer
hat er drauf geantwortet.
Senior Support Escalation
Officer. Also der
ist richtig geil.
Ich meine, das ist halt ein ganz normaler
Support-Ticket-Bearbeitungs-Typ
bei Microsoft. Der weiß
wahrscheinlich auch nichts.
Zumindest
hat die Antwort überhaupt nicht
geholfen. Null Aussagekraft,
außer, dass es langsam ist.
Übrigens, eine der ersten Antworten
von Microsoft davor war noch, wir sollen es
mal mit Windows über Samba probieren, ob es schneller
ist. Unsere
Anfrage war explizit für NFS mit Linux.
Wir haben explizit gefragt, warum
es mit Linux und NFS langsam ist
und die Antwort von Microsoft war,
probier es mal mit Samba unter Windows.
Aber witzigerweise,
wenn man es mit Samba unter Linux unter Windows
probiert hat, war das Ganze noch langsamer.
Naja,
zumindest war die Antwort
von dem Microsoft Support-Mensch
null hilfreich, aber
die letzte
Zeile war, wenn dieses Problem
damit gelöst ist,
bitte schließen Sie das Ticket.
Ich weiß nicht, in welcher Parallelwelt
Microsoft lebt, das frage ich mich öfters.
Wie habt ihr eigentlich das mit, das ist Teil des
Mail-Problems.
Achso, das Mail-Problem,
das Mail-Problem haben wir ganz einfach gelöst.
Wir haben das einfach jetzt auf ein ordentliches
Storage geschoben und gut ist,
scheiße auf Microsoft Azure.
Ja, also das ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Okay,
so, lange
noch geschwätzt, 40 Minuten am Labern gewesen,
jetzt gucken wir uns ein paar Videos an.
Da bin ich, glaube
ich auch, ja.
Ja, ist so,
deswegen verwende ich jetzt Apollo
als App, das ist ganz okay.
Zum Reddit lesen, Infinite Scroll ist echt
der, der, so
Känzer des modernen Internets.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
warum,
warum man Infinite Scroll
gut finden kann.
Es ist einfach, es ist einfach schlecht.
Zumal Smartphones mittlerweile
so viele RAM haben und so leistungsfähig sind,
dass du bei den meisten Sachen
gar kein Infinite Scroll mehr brauchst.
Ich mein, jedes 0815-Smartphone
wird doch in der Lage sein,
einen Thread mit 50 Kommentaren
am Stück zu laden.
Ja, For Onyx ist tatsächlich
auch ganz gut.
Ja, ist echt so
richtiger Pains Champ.
Mal kurz durchscrollen.
Was, ich war sehr überraschung,
Wix.com-Support, aha.
Hatte dafür einen Kunden eine Anfrage,
die rufen dich dann ansprechen,
gutes, äh, wie?
Wirklich?
Ich hatte, ich hatte letztens wieder
das Vergnügen mit der polnischen Hotline
von unserem Provider.
War ein Switch kaputt?
Oder vermutlich
ein Switch kaputt?
Haben wir da angerufen
und dann hat die gesagt,
was ist kaputt?
Eine Switch?
Was ist denn eine Switch?
Ja,
Netzwerk, Netzwerk, da,
Switch ist wahrscheinlich kaputt.
Ah, eine Switch?
Bustabieren sie mal ihr Name?
Das war grausam wieder, mein Güte.
Also da bin ich echt,
also das ist schonmal ein Vorteil,
wenn du mit denen
ordentlich reden kannst.
Also Leute hier,
ihr habt das gelesen,
Wix.com, Alter.
Huge Support.
Was ist Infinite Scroll?
Infinite Scroll kann ich dir zeigen,
Infinite Scroll ist das da.
Alter.
Hört sich nach Corona an.
Ah gut, nee,
Corona ist jetzt vorbei,
Überschwemmung ist gerade angesagt.
Ich vergesse.
Zeig mal her.
Infinite Scroll ist das hier, guck mal.
Das hier.
Das hier ist Infinite Scroll.
Dass du quasi
nicht weiter plättern musst
auf die nächste Seite.
Sondern das automatisch lädt.
Das Problem ist nur,
du findest nichts mehr.
Und ein weiteres Problem ist,
also du kannst dir nicht merken, auf Seite 5
oder so war was interessantes.
Und ein weiteres Problem ist, du kannst nicht suchen.
Das ist eigentlich das größte Problem.
Angenommen ich weiß,
irgendjemand unter meinem Video
hat, keine Ahnung,
nehmen wir mal irgendwie ein Beispiel.
Das da.
Ich weiß, das hat irgendwo mal jemand unter meinem Video gepostet
und fand ich furchtbar interessant und will ich wieder finden.
Dann gehe ich in die kommentarische Steuerung
und es funktioniert nicht.
Das heißt,
in Wirklichkeiten, damit du das überhaupt richtig
durchsuchen kannst, musst du,
ich rede jetzt hier nicht von meinen Videos, weil in meinen Videos
kann ich es im YouTube Studio machen.
Theoretisch müsste ich jetzt in Videos
mit 5000 Kommentaren runterscrollen, bis alles
geladen ist und dann könnte ich
danach suchen. Es ist lächerlich.
Infinite Scroll ist echt der größte Scheiß
überhaupt, den man sich überlegt
hat für Webseiten.
Ich habe Systemintegration gelernt.
2007.
Ist schon
etwas länger her.
Twitch Chat ist Infinite Scroll.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Allerdings bei einem Chat
ist es okay. Es gibt ja bei vielen Sachen
ist es ja so.
Es hat seine Anwendungszwecke, aber
für alles verwendet ist es dann doof.
Ja, das ist schlecht.
Das spricht nicht
für eure Ausstattung auf der Arbeit.
Was ist das für ein Zeug?
Ach, das ist
dieser Skillshare-Abklatsch.
Habe ich jetzt öfter schon mal Werbung zugesehen.
Von denen habe ich jetzt schon öfters mal gute Sachen gehört,
was die Hardware angeht. Habe ich noch nie Kontakt
mit. Hat jemand von euch schon mal Kontakt
gehabt mit Ruckus,
oder was?
Ich habe ja schon öfters mal gute Sachen gehört,
was die Hardware angeht. Habe ich noch nie Kontakt
mit. Hat jemand von euch schon mal Kontakt
gehabt mit Ruckus,
oder wie spricht man die aus?
Ruckus? Ruckus Access
Points?
Spielst du eine PoE League? Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ja, ich habe die letzten drei Leagues
schon nicht mehr gespielt. Ich hätte mal wieder Bock auf PoE.
Was ist sinnvoller?
Systemintegration oder Anwendungsinfektion?
Naja, das kann man.
Alle drei Sachen sind sinnvoll.
Es kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Das kann man oder beziehungsweise
was dir lieber ist oder was deine Vorlieben
sind oder was du dir vorgestellt hast. Das kann man
so pauschal nicht sagen. Es gibt nichts davon,
was sinnvoller oder weniger sinnvoll ist.
Also das hat alles seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Sehr gute Erfahrung gemacht.
Wie spricht man die aus? Ruckus?
Nice.
So, dann gucken wir uns jetzt ein paar YouTube Videos an.
Alter, was habe ich denn im Hals?
Ich muss noch kurz ein bisschen Tee trinken.
Okay, auf geht's.
Und guck mal, ich kriege meine eigenen Videos vorgeschlagen.
Leute, Leute.
Das Wichtigste, ich verrate euch jetzt
meinen YouTube Hack.
Das Wichtigste, was man für die YouTube Algorithmus machen kann,
ist, immer Videos anklicken,
die einem empfohlen werden,
weil das
mag der YouTube Algorithmus.
Also wenn ihr irgendwie, ich rede das nicht
explizit von mir, wenn ihr irgendeinen Content Creator
supporten wollt, klickt
einfach mal das Video an, wenn es euch empfohlen wird.
Das ist für den YouTube Algorithmus
das Beste überhaupt, weil
umso beliebter das
ist bei eigenen Abonnenten, umso weiter,
also umso breiter wird das Video
weiter empfohlen.
Also ich persönlich gehe mittlerweile davon aus,
dass der YouTube Algorithmus ungefähr folgendermaßen
funktioniert. Zumindest zu
90%, da kommen immer noch so ein bisschen
Sachen drumherum rein, dass man auch mal
Content findet,
den man normalerweise nicht kennt. Also ich denke,
dass der YouTube Algorithmus zum größten Teil so funktioniert.
Du lädst ein Video hoch
und es wird erstmal geguckt,
wie viele eigene Abonnenten klicken das an,
wie viele eigene Abonnenten gucken das, Dauer,
Klickrate und sonst was.
Dann wird das anhand dessen,
das ist übrigens gar nicht so sehr entscheidend,
also meine persönliche Vermutung,
ich kann ja den Source Code nicht angucken.
Aber dieser Stage ist noch gar nicht
so entscheidend für den
langfristigen Erfolg, wie es teilweise die meisten
Leute denken. Ich habe ja schon viele Videos geguckt,
so nach dem Motto, so drückst du den Algorithmus
aus. Das ist erstmal für YouTube
nur ein erstes Anhaltszeichen,
weil in der Regel gucken sich natürlich eigene
Abonnenten den Kram am liebsten an.
Und da haben sie schon erstmal einen ersten Datensatz,
wo sie erkennen,
wie lange gucken die Leute,
wie oft wird das Ganze angeklickt,
wie viel klicken sie rum, was sind die guten
Kapitel und sonst was.
Und dann
empfiehlt YouTube anderen
Leuten, die nicht deine Abonnenten
sind, dieses Video. Und ab da geht
es eigentlich los. Also sprich,
wie gut
gefällt Leuten, die dich
normalerweise, also die dich nicht
abonnieren, aber die dich selten oder nicht
gucken, wie gut gefällt denen
dieses Video? Und dann
haben die wahrscheinlich verschiedene Levels
oder es geht wahrscheinlich
konstant runter, weil es ist klar,
du hast erstmal, sag mal mal, 15-20%
der Leute, die klicken es instant an, weil
die sind deine Abonnenten, die gucken deine Videos gerne.
Wenn du nur 5%
der Leute, denen es empfohlen
wird, die dich sonst nicht gucken
und nicht abonniert haben, erreicht mit diesem Video,
weil das sie draufklicken, dann ist
das für YouTube schon ziemlich gut.
Und
dann entscheidet YouTube, okay,
die zeigen
es erstmal Leuten, die ähnliche
Interessen haben.
Die sagen, okay, die gucken
vielleicht Gaming, die gucken vielleicht Technik, aber
die gucken selten den Max. Dann zeigen sie erstmal denen.
So, und wenn dann die Anklickrate
immer noch gut bleibt, dann
zeigen sie es Leuten ein bisschen weiter
weg von dir.
Dann kriegen das dann vielleicht auch Leute
empfohlen, die
keine Ahnung,
eher
im Technologiebereich gucken
und wenn das dann immer noch gut ist,
die Anklickrate, dann wird es immer weiter empfohlen
und immer weiter empfohlen.
Deswegen sieht man ja auch, dass
wirklich
richtig erfolgreiche
Videos
meistens Videos sind, die viele
Leute ansprechen.
Es gibt natürlich auch Videos, die sind
in ihrem Bereich herausragend gut
und haben dann mehr oder weniger
alle Zuschauer, die es gibt,
die es interessiert, abgegriffen.
Zum Beispiel, kennen wir Ben Eater?
Der, der auf so
Breadboards, CPUs zusammensteckt
und sowas. Das ist
Content interessiert sicherlich nicht viele, aber
es gibt genug und es haben ganz hohe
Anteile gesehen, der Leute,
die es interessiert. Aber die meisten richtig
großen erfolgreichen Videos auf YouTube
sind Videos, die sich jeder
irgendwie angucken kann. Deswegen, hey,
es sind doch nicht umsonst Musikvideos und sowas
so erfolgreich.
Das guckt sich einfach Gott und die Welt an.
Kannst du das neue ApoRed Video anschauen?
Der hat echt...
Gibt's die noch? Der hat einen Fortnite
Let's Play Channel, das weiß ich. Ich wusste gar nicht, ob
der... ob der... dass der
wieder ApoRed macht.
Kritischer Hase, können wir uns angucken?
Nee, ich guck mir jetzt kein ApoRed an.
Dann ist das... da macht er im Zweifelsfall
wieder irgendwelche komischen Dinger, von wegen
Rucksack in die Menge werfen oder sowas.
Bestimmt Monka Toss.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal was an.
Ich hab jetzt eine Stunde gelabert.
Ich mach jetzt mal ein bisschen meine Klimaanlage an, weil hier drin ist
schon wieder 27 Grad.
Musik
So, also, was... was... was gucken wir uns...
was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Lass mal kurz gucken. Wie warm ist es denn draußen?
Lass mal kurz checken. Heimauto 21.
Draußen ist 21 Grad. Warum ist es beim 27 Grad
im Zimmer? Lull.
Na gut, das liegt daran, ich hab die Tür zu,
zwei Rechner an, zwei Monitore an.
Das hat schon ein bisschen Abwärme,
alles. Theoretisch kann ich das Fenster
aufmachen, aber ich kann auch einfach die
Klimaanlage anmachen.
Also schauen wir mal, was gucken wir uns an?
Wir lassen uns jetzt...
wir lassen uns jetzt Level Capture baiten.
Genau.
Wir lassen uns jetzt Level Capture... wir lassen uns
immer einmal Level Capture baiten
am Anfang des Streams.
Ach so, Battlefield Looks Like Trash wollten wir uns
hier angucken. Okay,
Battlefield... Battlefield Looks Like Trash wollten wir ja gucken.
Stimmt, stimmt. Okay, wir gucken
Battlefield Looks Like Trash. Ich predicte
ja immer noch, dass es ein Trollvideo.
Ich predicte immer noch, dass es ein Trollvideo
ist und die Leute haben es nicht gecheckt.
Ist das nicht Dings?
Ist das nicht... der hat früher Call of Duty
Videos gemacht. Ist das nicht...
Wings of Redemption?
Ist das nicht... ist der das nicht?
Doch oder?
Der ist nicht Commander Krieger.
Nein!
Das ist glaube ich
Wings of Redemption ist das, oder?
Egal was...
Alter, jetzt schreien sie rum.
What the fuck?
Was hat er denn?
Was du...
Was hat er denn für Probleme?
Okay Leute, das ist ein Trollvideo. Das muss ein Trollvideo sein.
Ein Tick lauter.
say what you want
about those games
Ja?
Ich finde damit hat er tatsächlich nicht Unrecht.
Dass... ein modernes Battlefield hätte es
im Event nach mir gehts schon vor fünf Jahren geben können.
Im Event nach mir gehts schon vor fünf Jahren geben können.
Advanced Warfare ist Trash,
aber Infinite Warfare ist legitimatey good,
but yall ain't ready for that conversation.
I give those games points
for A. Having not
just Multiplayer, but having
Zombies mode und
Story campaign
Kampagne juckt
Und sie kamen mit viel content
Hier verlieren wir die Kampagne
Und nur Multiplayer bekommen
Das stimmt
Keine Kampagne zu reden
Keine Singleplayer Kampagne
In Battlefield 2042
Und?
Weiter?
Nö
Das verstehe ich nicht wie man darauf rumreiten kann
Wenn man sich mal
Die alten Battlefield Teile anguckt
Erstens waren die lange Zeit nur Multiplayer
Und die Teile wo es Singleplayer gab
Fand ich den Singleplayer
Mit Ausnahmen eigentlich
Nicht wirklich gut
Wenn man sich Battlefield Singleplayer anguckt
Bad Company 1 fand ich cool
Weil es eben relativ offen war
Und quasi mehr oder weniger
Battlefield im Singleplayer
Das war cool
Bad Company 2 fand ich nicht mal so gut
Battlefield 3
Ist so ein Call of Duty Setting gewesen
Was ich beim ersten mal spielen richtig cool fand
Aber danach eigentlich festgestellt habe
Es hat relativ wenig Substanz
Battlefield 4 konntest du knicken
Hardline konntest du knicken
Battlefield 5 konntest du knicken
Battlefield 1 konntest du knicken
Die großen Singleplayer
Götter waren das halt einfach nicht
Und wenn die sich
Wenn schon schaden sie sich damit selbst
Weil es ist einfach so
Dass viele Leute Games
Wegen dem Singleplayer kaufen
Als aber Call of Duty ist es eben auch so
Also viele Leute kaufen die Call of Duty nicht
Weil sie Multiplayer Hardcore Cryant machen wollen
Sondern viele Leute kaufen sich es
Wegen einer coolen Singleplayer Kampagne
Und wenn sie keine Singleplayer Kampagne bringen
Das einzige was die sich damit schaden ist
Eventuell sich selbst
Wobei ich ja denke
Wenn man sich
Mein Singleplayer braucht schon ordentlich Ressourcen
Wenn man sich auf ordentliches Multiplayer
Und das was Battlefield groß gemacht hat
Konzentriert und das richtig gut macht
Ist es auf lange Sicht
Für das Game besser
Als da irgendeinen Singleplayer hinzu
Kacken
Und so muss man die letzten Singleplayers nennen
Von Battlefield
Wrong! 40 Dollar
Oh, der Kerl, Alter
Call of Duty
Did the exact same thing
And well, we saw how that
Turned out for that Call of Duty
Also, now that I think about it
That Call of Duty didn't only have Multiplayer
Black Ops 4 had Multiplayer
They also had
That Battle Royale Blackout
Which is the reason why they cut out the campaign
And then on top of that
You had Zombies Mode
And day one there was
Über was beschwert er sich denn jetzt eigentlich genau
Dass es kein Singleplayer hat
Also da hab ich jetzt wenig Schmerzen mit
Und außerdem
Wir wissen selber
Zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt noch relativ wenig
Was alles drin sein wird
Wir wissen, dass es drei verschiedene Spielmodi geben wird
Demnächst gibt's da übrigens
Wieder bei der nächsten
Ich glaub bei der EL Play gibt's dazu wieder was
Offiziell zumindest
Wie umfangreich das genau sein wird
Wir wissen, dass es glaube ich
Ich hab's, ich hab's vergessen
Wie viel sieben Maps oder so gibt
Standardmäßig
Das sagt aber noch lange nichts drüber aus
Was Replay, oh ich kann das Wort nicht ausspringen
Replayability
Angeht
Wie die Motivation in Multiplayer ist
Also unterm Strich wissen wir da eigentlich noch zu wenig von
Klar, es sieht erstmal
Das muss man auch wirklich ehrlich sagen
Es sieht erstmal nach nicht so viel aus
Wichtiger ist aber
Dass das
Eine gute Basis hat
Also das Spiel muss rauskommen
Mit ordentlich Content, mit ordentlich
Auf Fehlzahl an Content
Aber es muss guter Content sein
Sodass die Leute dabei bleiben und sie das
So wie sie's vorhaben über die Zeit erweitern können
Weil wenn das Game rauskommt
Und das Game ist einfach abgrundtief scheiße
Sind die Spieler weg nach einem Monat
Und sie können sich ihren neuen Content in die Haare schmieren
Die müssen mit dem initialen Content
Die Leute erst mal erreichen und halten
Überlegt euch mal
Wie, mein Rainbow Six
Es steht immer noch gut da
Überlegt euch mal wie sehr Rainbow Six
Durch die Decke gegangen wäre
Wäre es von Anfang an ein Game gewesen
Wo die Leute richtig, richtig nicht nur gehyped
Drauf gewesen wären, sondern von Anfang an gesagt
Ja Woll, das ist das Game was ich mir vorgestellt hab
Und dann jetzt noch mit dem langfristigen
Support
Powerwolf mal live gesehen, ne aber Ende des Jahres
Ist soweit, ich glaub September
Wenn das stattfindet
Die Diskussion ist doch so
Ausgelutscht alter
Das eine Game
Ist das eine Game und das andere Game
Ist das andere Game
Soll doch jeder
Spielen was er will
Natürlich kann man die Games vergleichen
Nicht nur vom Setting her
Die Games haben schon große Überschneidungen
Aber diese Diskussion ist so ausgelutscht
Ja ist ja gut
Träg dich mal ab
Warum weint er denn da
Hast du eine Empfehlung für ein Smartphone
Ne leider nicht
Ich hab selbst die letzten Jahre nur iPhones gehabt
Weil es von der Firma gestellt wird
Das ist ja
Keine Ahnung
Ok Leute, ich glaube das lohnt sich nicht zu gucken
Ich glaube das lohnt sich nicht zu gucken
Der hat sicherlich
Ich weiß immer noch nicht genau ob es getrollt ist
Oder nicht
Es gibt mit Sicherheit
Viele Kritikpunkte an Battlefield 42
Battlefield 2042
Aber ich finde die nicht
Gut verpackt in dem Fall
Übrigens ist euch mal aufgefallen
Dass YouTube immer noch
Battlefield 6 drinne stehen hat
In den Tags
Meine Videos wo ich dann drüber mich
Geht steht auch Battlefield 6
Anscheinend war bei YouTube
In den letzten zwei Monaten
Keiner in der Lage das Spiel umzubenennen
Oder vielleicht ist es
Hardcoded und YouTube kann es nicht umbenennen
Nachdem es einmal eingefügt wurde
Man weiß es nicht
Das gucken wir jetzt nicht
Ok wir lassen uns jetzt
Wir lassen uns mal eine Runde von Levelcap
Chibane
Das ist eine Runde Chibane von Levelcap
Stimmt doch überhaupt
Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht
DICE hat gesagt
Doch doch es stimmt
DICE hat gesagt es gibt erst Infos
In zwei Wochen
In einer Woche oder so
Wann ist EA Play
Also die einzige Info die DICE
Gegeben hat ist die Info
Dass es bald Infos gibt
Ok ich habe nichts gesagt
Das habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt
Aber es war eigentlich schon jedem klar
Dass es Crossplay gibt
Ist ja klar
Das Game ist ja auch viel kleiner
Als der PS4 und Xbox One
Wisst ihr was das lustige sein wird am Ende
Dass es wahrscheinlich das bessere Game ist
Mit weniger Spielern und kleineren Maps
Das ist aber auch nichts neues
Das ist nichts neues
Das stand sogar auf dem ersten
Dass du Crossprogression hast
Und das mitnehmen kannst
Das stand sogar auf dem aller ersten Ankündigungs-PDF
Das ist nichts neues
Ok das ist ein Video um Videos
Zu machen
Ich gehe davon aus
Dass du es zumindest auf der Playstation
Ausstellen kannst
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen
Dass man auf jeder Plattform Opt-out machen kann
Achso ja
Ich finde das gut mit Crossplay
Übrigens was man im Hintergrund sieht
Ist eines der Probleme
Die ich mit Battlefield 2042 habe
So weit wie man es jetzt gesehen hat
Das Spiel sieht nice aus
Die Wettereffekte sehen auch nice aus
Das Problem ist nur
Und man sieht das auch schon ein bisschen
Bei Warzone oder bei vielen neueren Multiplayer-Shootern
Die da keinen Wert drauf legen
Dass es eben so
Wie heißt das auf Deutsch
So kleinteilig ist
Dass du so schlecht was siehst
Ich mein
Wenn da hinten jetzt irgendein Dude steht
Den siehst du doch nicht
Und je nachdem wie das Spotten funktioniert
Kannst du auch nicht einfach mal ins Leere spotten
Und den Highlighten
Oh doch so viel
50.000 Accounts nach ein paar Monaten
Das ist ja nix
Das ist nix
Ja das ist nix
Ne also
Dass Ravensoft irgendwas auf die Reihe kriegt
Bezweifle ich
Residenz Lieber
Ja gut
Die Time to Kill in Warzone
Ist ja auch mittlerweile total übertrieben
Ich hab ja auch mal so 2-3 Monate gespielt
Ich hab's nie Hardcore gegrindet
Aber da war das noch okay
Und ich hab's danach noch ein bisschen verfolgt
Du hattest ja teilweise irgendwelche DMR Rifles
Da hast du 2 mal getappt und der Gegner war tot
Und ich mir gedacht
Was ist das für eine Balance
Oder teilweise irgendwelche Sniper
One hits across the map
Also das war echt balance technisch höchst fragwürdig
Wobei man halt sagen muss
Das ist
Das Warzone Balancing ist typisches
Microtransaction Balancing
Also es kommt irgendwas raus
Und Teile von
Also es kommt irgendeinen Package raus
Und Teile von diesem Package sind halt
Massive OP, warum?
Damit die Leute sich das Package kaufen
Oder den neuen Pass kaufen oder was auch immer
Das sieht man auch wunderbar
Bei MOBAs oder anderen
Multiplayer Games, aber bei MOBAs ist es auch oftmals so
Dass wenn neue Helden released werden
Dass die neuen, bei Heroes of the Storm war es extrem
Krass, aber das war halt Blizzard Taktik
Da kommt
Held raus
Und Balloll, Balloll weiß ich nicht
Aber Balloll ist es garantiert auch so
Kommt ein neuer Held raus
Und der Held ist erst mal
Mindestens die erste Woche, wenn nicht die ersten 1-2 Wochen
Ops, fuck
Lang genug, dass es sich jeder kauft
Kurz genug, dass die Leute
Wegrennen
Also die ersten 1-2 Wochen ist es immer so
Und warum? Dass die Leute sich das kaufen, natürlich
Und dann kommt
Zumindest bei Heroes of the Storm
Da kommt typisches Blizzard Balancing
Blizzard Balancing kennen wir ja
Blizzard Balancing ist was, was sich nicht einpendelt
Sondern fast von
OP zu useless
Bounced, ne? Also
Normales Balancing
Ist ja irgendwie sowas
Ne?
Wir machen hier big brain
Normales Balancing wäre ja sowas
Du fängst, du fängst, das Game kommt raus
Das Game kommt raus
Und der Held ist keine Ahnung
Der Held ist OP
Dann wird der Held genervt
Du schießt ein bisschen übers Ziel hier raus
Dann buffst du den Held wieder ein bisschen
Und dann pendelt sich das
Halbwegs ein
Es ist ein bisschen OP
Es ist ein bisschen underpowered
So wäre
Normales Balancing
Blizzard Balancing ist im Prinzip so
Permanent
Overpowered as fuck useless
Das ist Blizzard Balancing
So, und so haben wir das
Normales Balancing, weiß nicht was für den los ist
Ist Extraction nicht der Zombie Modus?
Oder ist das was anderes?
Es gibt doch auch irgendeinen Rainbow Six Zombie Modus jetzt
Ja, anscheinend, anscheinend
Das ist das
Das habe ich gelesen
Das habe ich gelesen, das finde ich auch geil
Das willst du euch mal anhören
Ich hoffe er erzählt es ein bisschen detaillierter
Das ist richtig geil
Das ist zu geil oder?
Das ist halt echt kacke
Stell dir mal vor
Du liegst irgendwelche geheimen Regierungsdokumente
Du bist so blöd
Oder kommst du in den Knast
Weil du einen Panzer in einem Game verbessern willst damit
Was zum Geier ist Netflix Gaming?
Ich habe jetzt nicht zu...
Netflix Games Library?
Will Netflix jetzt auch einen Games Launcher rausbringen?
Oder was?
Die sind ein bisschen spät?
Wenn es nichts extra kostet
Naja es kostet garantiert in irgendeiner Art und Weise extra
Du wirst auf jeden Fall dafür
Also letztendlich jeder dein Abo bezahlt
Bezahlt das in irgendeiner Art und Weise
Das muss halt immer klar sein
Selbst wenn der Abo Preis sich in erster Linie
Erstmal vielleicht die erste Zeit nicht ändert
Du bezahlst den Kram auf jeden Fall früher oder später mit
Ob du ihn benutzt oder nicht
Pupke
Läuft Pupke eigentlich mittlerweile halbwegs gescheit?
Oder ist die Performance immer noch krottenschlecht?
Ich mein eine Sache die mich persönlich schon immer an der Pupke Grafik gestört hat
Hier sieht man es, wenn die hier Auto fahren sieht man es eigentlich ganz gut
Also was mich an der Pupke Grafik schon immer ein bisschen gestört hat ist
Es ist komplett
Es hat keinerlei Eigenständigkeit die Pupke Grafik
Also ich finde die sieht so
Wie soll man das beschreiben?
Pupke sieht grafisch einfach komplett ohne Charakter aus
Ja das trifft es ganz gut
Genau Leute
Es sieht einfach so
Langweilig von der Grafik aus
Langweilig ist der falsche Punkt
So ohne eigene Note
Irgendwie so
Ja ffff
Ich mein es ist besser geworden als vor
Als das noch
Ist das eigentlich mittlerweile immer noch Early Access?
Das ist ja Standard mittlerweile das Beta und Irgendwas
Ich meine es ist besser geworden als vor
Als das noch
Ist das eigentlich mittlerweile immer noch Early Access?
Das ist ja Standard mittlerweile das Beta und Early Access dran stehen
Das ist deutlich besser als die paar Wochen wo ich das gespielt habe
Also die wenigsten sieht die Beleuchtung mittlerweile halbwegs okay aus
Halbwegs halbwegs okay
Ich bin froh dass ich nicht der einzige bin der Probleme mit Steam Deck und Stream Deck hat
Ja
Und das wird das größte Problem für die Casual Leute sein
Das habe ich ja auch bei mir im Video gesagt
Es gibt mittlerweile viele Spiele die unter Linux laufen
Und man kriegt auch nochmal genauso viele Spiele mit ein paar einfachen Tweaks zum laufen
Aber es gibt einen riesen Pool an Spielen der nicht gescheit läuft
Oder eben halt Tweaks braucht
Und das kannst du so einem 0815 User nicht zumuten
Wir können das, wir haben damit kein Problem
Wir gehen in Proton Settings, Wine Settings, was auch immer
Machen irgendwelche Config Dateien Einträge
Aber das macht der 0815 User den sie damit
Ich weiß ja nicht mal genau wen sie damit ansprechen wollen ehrlich gesagt
Das macht er einfach nicht
Ja aber einfach Windows installieren
Das macht ein 0815 User auch nicht
Ein 0815 User will das Ding einschalten
Und will sein Steam Account verknüpfen
Und will dann auf irgendein Spiel klicken oder starten und spielen ohne Probleme
Wir können das machen
Also wenn wir ein bisschen Ahnung von der Technik haben
Dann können wir das machen
Aber der normale User möchte das nicht
Und er kann das nicht und er will das auch nicht
Genau das ist das was ich gesagt habe im letzten Video
Die Out of Box Experience ist wichtig genau
Und man sieht das, ich habe in meinem Video dazu
Waren auch ganz viele Leute die gesagt haben
Max, Linux Gaming ist doch mittlerweile richtig gut, richtig nice
Und ich muss den Leuten ja zustimmen
Linux Gaming ist im Vergleich von vor 6-7 Jahren
Ist das viel viel besser
Aber guck mal
Ich glaube ProtonDB, können wir mal gucken
Aber schauen wir mal
Ein gutes Beispiel dafür ist Dragon Age Origin
Das ist ein Spiel von 2010 oder so
Wann kam das raus?
Dragon Age Origins kam raus
Release Date
2009, sagen wir 2010
Das ist ein Spiel von 2010
Die Gold Edition, die Ultimate Edition
Weil das ist was die meisten Leute heute haben
So das Spiel läuft in Ordnung
Aber man sieht es ja auch schon an den ganzen Kommentaren
Man muss öfters als man denkt
Irgendwelche Tweaks von Hand vornehmen
Das ist kein Problem für Leute die technisch ein bisschen versiert sind
Die meisten Tweaks sind easy as fuck
Hier guck
Hier muss Wine so starten
Dann muss er irgendwie Full Disable, Mouse Capture
Alles okay, ist für uns kein Hindernis
Aber für den normalen User
Der das Ding startet, Dragon Age anmacht
Und ich mein, man sollte eigentlich erwarten können
Dass dieses Ding ein 12 Jahre altes Spiel dann gut spielen kann
Ist das nicht zumutbar?
Das funktioniert einfach nicht
Was verstehe ich nicht so ganz
Die sagen ja angeblich läuft dann alles drauf
Ja gut, die können viel sagen wenn der Tag lang ist
Was die im Hintergrund laufen haben ist folgendes
Das ist das was sie hier drauf laufen haben
Das da ist ein Wine Fork
Mit zusätzlichem Kram
Und das hier ist ein Layer der DirectX auf Walken übersetzt
So und das in Kombination sorgt dafür dass Spiele ohne weitere Anpassungen erstmal lauffähig sind in der Theorie
Natürlich nur so weit
Wie nicht irgendwelche Bugs in Proton oder DX4K oder nicht implementierte Sachen verwendet werden
Und das kommt halt öfters vor als man denkt
Dementsprechend dank diesen zwei Sachen laufen ja ebenso viele Spiele auch so gut
Aber trotzdem auch viele Spiele die eigentlich überhaupt kein Problem sein sollten
Zum Beispiel ein zwölf Jahre alt Strangage Origins
Was auch noch ein sehr beliebtes Game ist
Gehen halt immer nur nach Tweaks
Und natürlich die können jetzt anfangen irgendwelche Tweaks einzubauen
Das müssen sie ja auch
Aber trotzdem darf man nicht von ausgehen
Dass die Probleme bei Release einfach weg sind
Die Probleme wird es immer noch geben
Die Leute werden das starten werden in Steam Account verbinden
Und sich wahnsinnig darüber aufregen dass die Spiele nicht richtig funktionieren
Doch doch jetzt können die einbauen das müssen sie bloß mal machen
Das ist halt nicht einfach mal so gemacht
Und einen großen Vorteil den das Ganze haben könnte ist folgendes
Also eines der größten Probleme was Spiele unter Linux angeht
Zumindest wenn man sich hier die Top 10 Games anguckt ist Anti-Cheat
Warum funktioniert PUBG nicht Anti-Cheat
Warum verwendet Apex nicht Anti-Cheat
Was zum Geier ist das überhaupt
Was ist das
What the f
China Chinesen Kram
Stimmt irgendein MMO oder so
Das ist Anti-Cheat
So und das ist was wo das wirklich was bringen könnte
Sollte Steam Deck sich ansatzweise gut verkaufen
Könnte ich mir vorstellen dass mehr Hersteller Interesse dran haben
Und wir reden ja hier von Sachen nicht unbedingt jetzt über Steam
Da könnte ich mir vorstellen dass einige andere Hersteller auch anfangen ihre Sachen Anti-Cheat technisch lauffähig zu machen
Mit Proton und DX4K
Das könnte tatsächlich für Linux Gaming einiges positives bewirken
Ich glaube trotzdem dass das in die Hose geht mit Steam Deck wie sie sich das vorstellen
Vor allem bei Workstation
Das weiß ich nicht
Die werden sicherlich ein bisschen was in der Hinterhand haben
Und es wird bei Release sicherlich auch ein verbessertes Proton geben haben sie ja schon gesagt
Aber die Probleme sind nicht einfach weg
Ja gut das machen sie ja nicht
Aktuell steht auf der Seite
Verknüpfe deine ganze Steam Library
Your Steam Library Anywhere
Und das ist einfach nicht so
Das wird einfach nicht so sein
Ohne Tweaks
Also
Your Steam Library Anywhere
Das heißt eindeutig ich kann mal
Also so wie die Werbeaussage ist
Dass sie sich da am Ende irgendwie rausreden ist klar
Aber
Wenn man so eine Aussage trifft bedeutet das
Man behauptet
Ich mache das Ding an verknüpfe meine Steam Library
Und ich kann meine gesamte Steam Library da drauf benutzen
Das heißt das
Wenn man sowas schreibt
Natürlich reden die sich am Ende irgendwie wieder raus wenn das nicht funktioniert
Sie schreiben hier ja auch nirgendswo dass es spielbar ist was eigentlich lustig ist
Ne ne Max interpretierst zu viel das ist Marketing
Hey das ist die Aussagen woran
Man kann doch nicht sagen uns ist bewusst dass uns Scheiße erzählt wird
Weil wir wissen dass es nicht so ist
Man muss sie daran messen was sie sagen
Und wenn sie sagen Your Steam Library Anywhere
Dann müssen sie sich daran messen lassen ob das ebenso funktioniert oder nicht
Dass uns jetzt schon klar ist dass das nicht so ist
Es ist jetzt kein Freifahrtschein für Valve zu sagen dass es so ist
Zumal was meint ihr denn wie irgendein 0815 casual Käufer das interpretiert
Stellt euch mal vor die Oma die einen Weihnachtsgeschenk für den Enkel kaufen will
So und die liest Your Steam Library Anywhere
Sowas was ich die Oma weiß der Enkel spielt immer über Steam oder so
Die liest Your Steam Library Anywhere
Die denkt sich und genau das was man sich denken soll
Die denkt sich ok dann kann der Typ halt seine ganzen Steam Spiele da drauf spielen
Dass die sich hier schon wieder ein bisschen raus reden ist das andere
Aber das ist auch kein Freifahrtschein zu sagen ja nö das ist auch nicht so wild
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen es ist auch vollkommen egal was die schreiben
Wenn das nicht funktionieren wird
Wenn die Leute davon anfangen ein Problem dann wird das Ding ein Flop
Das kannst du knicken
Also ich gehe davon aus dass Linux echt ein riesen Problem für das Ding wird
Ich finde es gut dass es Linux Gaming eventuell voranbringt
Aber ich glaube das wird ein riesen Problem werden
Ja gut das Problem hast du ja mit Steam OS dann nicht
Da hast du eh nur Steam
Ja die werden erstmal nicht laufen
Wisst ihr wofür das Ding richtig gut werden wird
Wenn irgendjemand mobil Emulator Zeug spielen will
Dafür ist das gut weil Oldschool Emulator Kram brauchen nicht allzu viel Leistung
Und vielleicht vielleicht haben wir Glück
Und es gibt bis dahin das darf man dann zwar das ist dann zwar Monkratos
Aber man selbst darf das machen
Vielleicht gibt es bis dahin einen halbwegs brauchbaren Switch Emulator
Und dann kannst du natürlich Switch Spiele da drauf spielen
Gibt es jetzt? Es gibt keine gescheiten Switch Emulator
Es gibt die Dinger mit den japanischen Namen
Irgendwas mit R und irgendwas mit J oder mit Y
Ja genau
Aber die funktionieren nicht
Also die funktionieren für das was sie sind ganz gut
Aber du bist auch weit davon entfernt
Dass du einfach sagen kannst
Ich nehme den x beliebigen Switch spielen und spiele das
Also nur weil ein Emulator existiert heißt das ja noch lange nicht
Dass die Spieler auch da prinzipiell mal gut drauf laufen
So wenn das der Fall ist wäre das natürlich cool
Und zum Emodieren älterer Spiele wenn man die mobil haben will ist das auch ein super Ding
Also wer da drauf Super Nintendo N64, DS, PS1 vielleicht noch emulieren will oder so
Ist das wahrscheinlich mobil das geilste was man haben kann
Wii, auch noch Gamecube
Wobei weiß ich doch die sind mittlerweile ganz ok
Wii U geht ja auch schon halbwegs brauchbar
Dafür ist das alles ok
Wobei man da sagen muss dass ein Wii U Emulator sicherlich viel Leistung frisst
Aber gerade die Oldschool Games
PSP
Gibt es eigentlich den Vita Emulator
Aber gerade so gerade sagen wir mal so gerade
Super Nintendo N64
DS, PSP und sowas
Die dürften nicht allzu viel Leistung ziehen auf dem Ding
Das heißt da kannst du wahrscheinlich auch mal 5-6 Stunden spielen
Was ziemlich cool ist
Also dafür ist das nice
So, kommt mal weiter
Das stimmt übrigens nicht dass es excellent compatibility mit most games hat
Das stimmt einfach nicht
Es hat für Linux Gaming Verhältnisse excellent compatibility
Aber es hat für die Gesamtanzahl an Games
Also das hört sich jetzt so an als laufen die meisten Games da ohne Probleme anklicken ohne es geht
Und das ist halt nicht so
Es laufen viele Games aber von einem Großteil der Games sind wir noch weit entfernt
Der Screen ist ein Ticken größer als auf der Switch
Der Switch ist glaube ich 6,2 Zoll und das ist ein 7 Zoll Bildschirm
Läuft da Fortnite?
Wenn du Windows installiert hast definitiv
Der ist nicht schlecht
Der nimmt einfach die Trailer von anderen Channels
Das hätte ich auch machen sollen
Anstatt die Webseite selbst zu filmen in meinem Video
Einfach die Trailer von anderen Channels nehmen easy
Der Steam OS ist ein Arch Linux mit KDE
Exakt so sehe ich das auch
Deswegen habe ich das ja auch so geschrieben bei mir im Video und dann was zu gesagt
Switch und Steam Deck überschneiden sich nur am Rande
Switch und Steam Deck überschneiden sich nur in dem einen Fall
Wo Leute aktuell eine Switch gekauft haben
Weil sie Spiele die sie eigentlich auf dem PC spielen wollen
Und die es für die Switch gibt diese Games mobile im Handheld Format spielen wollen
Sprich sowas wie den Switcher oder Doom Eternal
Und dann haben sie auch noch die schlechtere Varianten davon
Weil ganz ehrlich, Switcher auf der Switch ist ja massiver Paintschamp
Paintschamp in DS ist das auf der Switch
Und für die Leute da ist das diese Überschneidung
Okay, für die ist das natürlich gut
Aber die größten Teil der Leute erreichen die damit gar nicht
Die Switch ist eine geschlossene Plattform von Nintendo für Nintendo Games für Nintendo Services
Und die Leute die das haben wollen, die finden das bei Steam Deck nicht
Und das was die Leute bei Steam Deck finden, finden die Leute in der Regel bei der Switch nicht
Die Switch kann sogar Crysis run
Es gibt noch glaube ich einen Crysis Port für die Switch, oder?
Ich weiß aber nicht wie gut der ist
Und das war's für diese Woche im Gaming
Wie immer, danke fürs Zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal
Woop woop woop
Das Spiel habe ich nicht für die Switch
Ich hab die Switch auch ein halbes Jahr oder so schon immer angehabt
Aber contentmäßig hat Nintendo eh schon die letzten Jahre über krass Probleme
Die bringen ab und zu immer eigene Games raus
Mittlerweile leider auch recht halbherzige Dinger
Und dann kommt halt wieder irgendwie ein ja nichts
Und wenn dann was rauskommt von den großen Titeln
Ist es so technisch fragwürdige Dinger wie das letzte Pokemon oder Dings
Dieser Crossover, dieser Breath of the Wild
Was war das für ein Crossover Hyrule Boreas, das ist ein Crossover aus Dynasty
Dynasty Boreas, Dynasty Dings und Zelda
Weiß gar nicht, genau
Und das letzte ruckelt erst, fuck
Das hat 10 FPS teilweise
Was machen denn die Programmierer da
Sind die alle irgendwie unfähig oder was
Gerade auf einer Switch
Wo du von Anfang an weißt, für was für eine Plattform du entwickelst
Da sollte das doch möglich sein
Pokemon hatten sie diese Open Source Zone
Wo die Gegner 2mm vor dir aufgeploppt sind
10 FPS sind besser als 9 FPS
Ja nach der Logik sind 11 FPS natürlich noch besser
Das heißt dementsprechend Spiele mit 13 FPS ist dann eigentlich das höchste der Gefühle
Also besser geht es ja eigentlich gar nicht
Obwohl wir wissen ja alle 12 FPS pro Auge 24 FPS reicht
Weil das menschliche Auge kann eh nicht mehr wahrnehmen
Das ist ja schon lange Zeit bekannt
Warum nicht Max FPS, oh huge
Big Brain Joke, da ist noch nie einer vorne drauf gekommen
Du musst noch Kappa dahinter setzen, stimmt, stimmt
Heutzutage muss man bei allem Kappa dazu sagen
Oder irgendwas in der Richtung, was die Leute noch verstehen, wenn es nicht ernst gemeint ist
Also Kappa
Oder Full Moon Emoji, weil Kappa Twitch Only Ding ist
Kappa ist eigentlich der beste Beweis, für das wir Twitch Emotes überall brauchen
Kappa ist so bekannt und beliebt mittlerweile, dass die Leute es außerhalb von Twitch verwenden
Und das geht so weit, dass die Leute wo es keinen Kappa gibt
Mittlerweile das hier als Kappa Ersatz verwenden
Genau, dass die Leute das hier als Kappa Ersatz verwenden
Weil manche Emoji-Auto-Vervollständigung Kappa eben dieses Ding nehmen
Wenn du beim Abendessen Monka esst, warum sehe ich kein Problem drin
Sehe ich überhaupt kein Problem drin
Ich sage sogar manchmal, ich habe letztens aus Versehen auf der Arbeit gesagt
0W in irgendeinem Meeting ist richtig eng geblieben
0W
Hat keiner gecheckt
Richtig painstab, hat glaube ich keiner gecheckt
Aber man muss sagen, es war letztens eine Umfrage bei uns
Hat irgendeiner eine Umfrage auf der Arbeit rumgeschickt in irgendeinem Meeting
Und da sollten wir abstimmen nach dem Motto, was verbinden sie mit der Cloud
Und da habe ich geantwortet, Poggers
Einfach so, weil mir nichts anderes eingefallen ist
Und ich mal einen Twitch Emote posten wollte
Und das hat er sogar vorgelesen
Da hat er gesagt, ich lese hier schon Poggers
Und da war ich mir nicht ganz sicher
Hat er das jetzt einfach nur vorgelesen, weil es die erste Antwort war
Oder hat er das verstanden
Da bin ich mir echt nicht sicher, hat er verstanden, was mit Poggers gemeint ist
Oder hat er es einfach nur so vorgelesen
Vielleicht leckt der Typ keine Critical Information, vielleicht weiß er es einfach
Ich habe auch, ich glaube auch, dass er es verstanden hat
Ich glaube auch, dass er es verstanden hat
Weil die sind ja mittlerweile auch nicht mehr alle Boomer 60 plus
Wie alt war der, ich würde sagen so in meinem Alter, so 30 oder so
Also der kann das durchaus verstanden haben
Nee, so schnell wie er geantwortet hat, hat er das nicht gegoogelt
Also ich gehe davon aus, der wusste es, der wusste es
Sicher war ich nicht
Also ihr seht, ich tue alles dafür, Twitch Emotes in die normale Sprache zu überführen
Es ist aber ein schwerer Weg, ja
Aber der Gelegenheit, Moment, Moment
Twitch Emotes Song, wartet mal kurz
Kekona, Kekona Time Leute
Kekona
Kekona Time
So muss das sein
Kappa Pock Jam
Swift Rage
Verwendet keiner mehr
Easy
Pock Jam ist auch nicht mehr, das war es, das war mal
Defranca Z
Kekona
Kappa
Excellent, so, das musste jetzt mal wieder sein
Haben wir das auch durch
Kappa gleich Greyface Snow Space
Das da, das ist so old school
Das ist ja, das ist schon 2015 oder so
Wenn es mal reicht
erreicht, Greyface NoSpace. Und vor allem haben die Leute das damals ja auch tatsächlich
sind da drauf reingefallen. Das ist, das ist eine der Ur-Copy-Pastas auf Twitch schlechthin
Kappa gleich Greyface NoSpace. Ok gucken wir mal weiter, was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Sowas habt ihr noch nicht gesehen, PC nach Wohnungsbrand. Ok, der Auer, was haben wir
heute? Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Video, wir sind mal wieder
bei Caseking, da werden PCs von Zuschauern abgeholt, getunet, wieder neue PCs zurückgebracht.
Also könnt ihr sehr gerne mal bei Caseking beim YouTube-Kanal vorbeischauen, da gibt's
dann auch eine sehr interessante Folge, das ist ein abgefuckterer PC, ich zeig's euch
mal. Die Wasserkühlung konnte quasi das Haus nicht kühlen. Das war eben der erste Kandidat
für dieses Projekt, wo dann ist quasi Pimp my PC und Caseking bringt eben den Zuschauer
dann einen neuen PC. Was sollen die da pimpen? Das Ding ist komplett im Arsch, die können
den austauschen. Das ist nicht Pimp my PC, das ist Replace my PC. Naja, ich hab in einer
von diesen Folgen dann gedacht, ok schau ich mir das System mal so ein bisschen genauer
an. Ihr seht die CPU fehlt, die CPU hat tatsächlich noch funktioniert, also auch wenn hier alles
komplett abgefackelt ist, das war auch ein bisschen größerer Aufwand. Die CPU war wahrscheinlich
geschützt durch den Kühler und das Boardraum. Aber die CPU funktioniert noch, die bekommt
jetzt eben der Teilnehmer. Guckt euch mal den RAM an. Guckt euch mal die RAM-Slots an.
Die haben auch schon bessere Zeiten gesehen. Die CPU bekommt er einfach wieder als Gudi
mit zu seinem neuen PC dazu als Schlüsselanhänger. Deswegen hab ich die jetzt nicht mehr hier,
aber das Video könnt ihr bei Caseking sehen, falls ihr das wollt. Ja, ich dachte mir jetzt
so, wenn die CPU schon funktioniert, wie sieht es eigentlich mit der Grafikkarte aus? Also
es ist ja extrem viel geschmolzen, so Kunststoffe, die schmilzen ja immer sehr schnell, je nach
dem was für ein Typ ist zwischen, ich sag mal zwischen 80-140 Grad, da schmilzen die
meisten Kunststoffe. Und eigentlich ist das eine Temperatur, die für Leiterplatten und
sowas jetzt ja nicht wirklich dramatisch ist. Also selbst 200 Grad ist eigentlich so lang
wie Sachen aus sind, ist halt kein Problem. Deswegen dachte ich mir, wir... Das hieß
ja auch daran, dass so viele Leute ihre Sachen im Ofen zusammenlöten. Also wenn irgendwie
einer irgendwelche PCBs macht, da gibt es ja viele Anleitungsvideos auch, die bestücken
das dann mit Teilen und stellen es in Ofen. Natürlich nicht unbedingt der Ofen, wo du
danach irgendwie Essen drin machst. Da ist dann auch 200 Grad drin. Oder was ich letztens
gesehen hab, irgendein Typ, der auf dem Bügeleisen gelötet hat. Richtig big brain, das muss
ich euch mal kurz zeigen. Was heißt Bügeleisen? Irgendetwas mit ein... Bügeleisen Englisch.
Einfach nur Iron, okay. Äh, okay. Äh, ja. Ich glaube, der Typ ist das. Guck mal, guck
mal, guck mal. Moment, was zum Ze... Wo zeigt der uns denn, dass es... Nein, wo löte
da den Kram dann? Äh, okay. Also ja, das äh... Vorwärts der Abschnitt?
genau, genau. Jetzt hat er die Paste mit dem Lötzinn drinne, jetzt setzt er
die Komponenten drauf, genau. Und jetzt macht das auf seinen Bügeleisen. Jetzt zeig her,
ich will das Bügeleisen sehen. Er zeig uns das Bügeleisen. Ah, doch, jetzt hier. Also
er löte sein Kram auf dem Bügeleisen zusammen. Was ich damit sagen will ist, die Digger halten
echt gut was aus. Ich hab, ich hab zwar übrigens mega gefailt. Ähm, ich wollte den Pin-Header
von einem Raspberry Pi rausmachen. Also dieses Ding. Diesen Header wollte ich aus dem Raspberry
Pi rausmachen, dass ich da was anderes reinstecken kann. Also das hier. So, und das ist ja gar
nicht so einfach, wenn das festgelötet ist, das wieder rauszubekommen. Was du machen kannst
ist natürlich, jede einzelne Lötstelle einfach, ähm, oder was heißt einfach, aufwendig,
du hältst da ein bisschen Kupfer dran, lötest das warm, saugst das weg, oder du nimmst
so einen Sauger, so einen Sauger, machst das warm und saugst das ein paar Mal weg und dann
geht das auch. Aber das ist echt, also was fest zu löten ist ein kleinerer Akt als
was abzubekommen. So, und dann hab ich mir gedacht, komm, ich machs mir mal einfach und
hab meine Heißluftgebläse genommen und hab den Raspberry Pi warm geblasen und hab das
versucht rauszuziehen. Und dann, dann, das hat auch funktioniert und danach hatte ich
ein Problem. Dadurch, nee nee nee, es hat funktioniert, dadurch, dass ich das einfach
rausgezogen hab, waren jetzt alle Lötstellen dreckig mit Lützen. Das heißt, ich konnte
nix neues reinstecken. Ich hab einfach nix neues reinbekommen, weil die, weil die ganzen
Lötstellen einfach zu waren noch mit Dreck. So, und dann hab ich mir gedacht, ok, jetzt
big brain move. Ich wollte, das war ein Raspberry Pi Zero und ich wollte einen Automation P-Head
draufsetzen, so ein Teil, so ein Teil wollte ich aufsetzen auf den Zero. So, und dann hab
ich mir gedacht, weißt du was, jetzt machen wir Big Brain Time. Ich hab einfach das Ding
wieder heiß gemacht und dann musste ich probieren, hier sieht man ja, so sieht es dann draufgesteckt
aus, dann musste ich probieren, diese Kontakte hier, das sind die Kontakte zum Raspberry
Pi, dann musste ich probieren, die Kontakte, da hab ich hier mit der Heißluft, mit dem
Heißluft rübergeheizt und dann musste ich versuchen, ganz schnell das Ding zu nehmen
mit ner Zange und draufzustecken, während noch alles heiß ist. Das war nicht so gut,
das war nicht so gut die Idee, weil erstens hab ich das Relay abgelötet oder abgepustet
damit und ich hab das Plastik komplett verzogen, war zu heiß und danach musste ich das Ganze
wieder raus machen und letztendlich, ich hab das ein paar mal gemacht, das hat dann irgendwann
funktioniert und es ging noch danach, es ging, ich hab das hier wieder angelötet, das Relay,
es hat alles noch funktioniert, also was ich damit sagen will ist, der Scheiß hält echt
ordentlich was aus, das was zuerst abgeht sind die Komponenten an den Lötstellen, aber
die Boards an sich, das ist äußerst robust. Die Grafikkarte hier noch rausbekommen, was
auch schwierig sein wird, weil ihr seht es hier zum Beispiel, das war mal ein Lüfter,
man sieht hier noch so ein bisschen den Motor, also der ging dann logischerweise hier oben
drin und ist dann hier runter geschmolzen und liegt das hier auf der Grafikkarte, das
muss ich dann mal versuchen alles weg zu bekommen, der Geruch ist übrigens auch ein absoluter
Traum, das ist ein richtiges Geruchserlebnis, sobald dieser PC...
Oh, die Verschwörungstheoristen, was ist denn eigentlich eine Bezeichnung für Verschwörungstheoretiker,
nicht Verschwörungstheoristen, eher nicht Verschwörungstheoretiker, die hätten jetzt
hier wieder White Power erkannt Leute, White Power, ein absoluter Traum, das ist ein richtiges
Geruchserlebnis, sobald dieser PC in irgendeinem Raum drin steht, ja, das war glaube ich
auch mal ein Lüfter hier, ja, das war auch mal ein Lüfter, also schon ziemlich krass,
wenn wir es irgendwie schaffen die Grafikkarte raus zu bekommen, dann wird es vielleicht
noch was, ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt.
Danke an dieser Stelle auch an unseren Partner, Exit, für das Protech Toolkit, also das werden
wir verwenden um...
Das, das hatte ich mir auch mal gekauft, ich, also wie soll ich das sagen, es ist eigentlich
so ziemlich alles überflüssig in diesem Kit, außer die Bits, weil die Bits sind halt
für Schrauben und Dinge, die man sonst nicht hat, diese ganzen Dinger kannst du komplett
vergessen, ich hab's ja mal live im Stream verbogen, diese Dinger kannst du komplett
vergessen, diese Plastik, den kannst du auch alle, das ist ein Anti-Static-Armband übrigens,
das Einzige, was gut ist in diesem iFixit Set, preisleistungsmäßig ist es durchaus
okay, iFixit, das Einzige, was aber wirklich sehr zu empfehlen ist, ist die Bitsammlung,
wenn man sowas noch nicht hat, weil dort eben sehr viele Bits dabei sind, die man sonst
nicht besitzt, ja, zum Beispiel hier diese komischen Sicherheitsdinger, dann hast du
hier was zum SIM-Karten rausmachen, dann hast du diese dreieckigen Dinger, die kann man
teilweise für China-Steckdosen zum Aufmachen, das ist tatsächlich sehr praktisch, aber
der Rest von diesem iFixit Toolkit, ja, ist ziemlich billig.
Zu versuchen, die Grafikkarte hier rauszubauen, aber ihr seht, da ist alles Wichtige dabei,
was man für so eine Operation bräuchte, davon wahrscheinlich relativ wenig, das Teil hier
vielleicht mal, um die Kunststoffteile hier hinter der Grafikkarte abzulösen, aber wir
haben hier eben auch das riesige Bit-Set, was für alle ist, ja, genau, das ist das,
ich muss noch sagen, der Schraubendreher, der dabei ist, das ist in Ordnung, aber wahnsinnig
begeistert bin ich nicht davon, aber zum Glück ist ein Adapter dabei, dass man die kleinen
Pins in jeden 0815-Bit-Halter einsetzen kann und ich nehme einfach meinen ganz normalen
Vera-Bit, wie heißt denn das Ding, dieser Vera-Bit-Bit-Clip-Halter, passt das mit Adapter
rein, dann ist alles gut.
Die Sachen, die man so am PC braucht, absolut super sind, also alle kleinen Aufsätze für
Nvidia-Grafikkarten mit verrücktem Torx und so weiter, also damit sollten wir auf jeden
Fall alles aufbekommen.
Weil, wenn man diesen Adapter verwendet, ich glaube, das ist der Adapter, da kann man nämlich
diese Dinger auch in Akkuschrauber rein machen und das ist dann wirklich ganz nice.
Wobei man halt fairerweise sagen muss, meistens brauchst du für die Dinger wirklich kein
Akkuschrauber, also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, geht mal an die Konsole mit dem Akkuschrauber
ran, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu vieles gut, also als Komplett-Set ist das durchaus
in Ordnung, das kann man auch verwenden, ist auch ok verarbeitet, auch diese ganzen Sachen,
das ist in Ordnung.
Also wenn man sonst nichts hat und sowas braucht, um Elektronik-Kram aufzukriegen, ist das nice,
man muss aber aufpassen, man sollte jetzt nicht denken, dass das irgendwie ein Elektronikerset
ist.
Also geht damit niemals irgendwie an Sachen unter Spannung dran, schon gar nicht 230 Volt,
aber auch niedrigere Sachen, da fabriziert ihr, macht ihr irgendwas kaputt, also ausschalten,
immer.
Nicht irgendwie auf blöde Ideen kommen.
Dann würden wir auf jeden Fall alles aufbekommen, Link dafür findet ihr auf jeden Fall unten
in der Beschreibung.
Wir werden jetzt als erstes mal versuchen, dieses Teil hier.
Das mit Akkuschrauber ist sogar relativ normal, also es verwendet heute eigentlich kaum noch
eine normale Schraube, wenn du mal rumguckst, auch, ich weiß nicht, ob wir irgendwie handwerkstechnisch
Tischler-mäßig hier vielleicht irgendjemand haben, aber ich hab letztens erst wieder
gehört, dass dort hauptsächlich Torx verwendet wird, also Kreuzschlitzschrauben und normale
Schrauben sind eigentlich out, zum größten Teil werden für die meisten Sachen heutzutage
Torx verwendet, auch handwerkstechnisch, also Torx und Akkuschrauber ist mittlerweile fast
nur die Standardkombi.
So ein bisschen abzupopeln, weil eigentlich, die Grafikkarte ist da hinten ja über die
Schrauben fest, das ist jetzt mal nicht das Problem, die kriegen wir auf jeden Fall ab,
die Kabel sehen auch noch okay aus, die können wir tatsächlich mal als erstes versuchen abzuziehen.
Klar, Ben Eater, kenn ich.
Ja, ich vermute mal, das wird ja kein Problem sein.
Boah, das für kohlte Zeug, äh.
Das Problem sein könnte ist, dass vielleicht die Anschlüsse von der Grafikkarte ein bisschen
angeschmolzen sind.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn jetzt da irgendwelche Schrauben reingeschmolzen sind ins Plastik,
ist auch doof rauszubekommen, das Metall wird nicht geschmolzen sein.
Also wie viel Temperatur braucht man, dass so eine Schraube schmilzt, 1200 Grad oder
so?
Weil nicht unmöglich, das jetzt da zu erreichen, aber doch eher unwahrscheinlich.
Dass wir da gar kein Bildschirm mehr anschließen können, aber im schlimmsten Fall machen wir
daraus einfach ein zweites Gerät und dann schauen wir, ob das erkannt wird im PC.
Schrauben, funktionieren.
Wenn du nix hast, um an Elektronik zu arbeiten, ist das okay.
Ja gut, wie gesagt, wenn du die Kram ausschaltest, ist das alles kein Ding, ja.
Also generell, ich würde es jetzt nicht so sehr empfehlen als Elektronikkram, sondern
halt eher, um Sachen aufzubekommen, wo der Hersteller nicht will, dass man die aufbekommt.
Das ist halt oftmals Elektronik.
Braucht jemand ein Stück Ram-Slot oder?
Ja, gib her.
Ich habe schon immer so einen abgebrochenen Ram-Slot gesucht.
Die Grafika bewegt sich, das Problem ist nur, dass hier diese riesen Haufen...
Zweimal 8-Pin.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein fettes Grafik, ein fettes Teil.
Da stand ja noch ein 1080 Ti drin oder sowas.
Ach da ist es, das ist eine Grafik-Hallung, die hier unten dran ist, oder?
Boah ey, was ein Ding.
Der Slot ist festgeschmort, hä?
Tja, was war das mal?
Könnte auch ein 1080 Ti gewesen sein, aber die Dinger sehen halt alle so aus.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, ob ich meine Aussage nochmal revidiere, weil die sieht echt etwas
mehr mitgenommen aus als die CPU.
Also da hat es echt heftig drunter gebrannt.
Was war es mal?
Wir schauen einfach mal unter die Backplate drunter und dann können wir uns wahrscheinlich
ein besseres Bild machen von dieser Geschichte.
Ansonsten, ja, innen, da ist nichts mehr zu machen.
Also ich habe jetzt die Schrauben mittlerweile mal von der Backplate weggemacht und jetzt
schauen wir mal, ob wir die überhaupt noch abgenommen bekommen oder ob die da komplett
sich selbst hingeklebt hat.
Jogo, danke schon für den Prime-Sub.
Also es sieht jetzt auf den ersten Blick jetzt nicht so schlecht aus.
Nö, sieht in Ordnung aus.
Das kann durchaus noch funktionieren, das Teil.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich würde sogar mal drauf tippen, dass es noch geht.
Das Problem ist, hier sind so viele kleine SMDs drauf und wenn der falsche an irgendeiner
Stelle fehlt, dann ist es schon vorbei.
Die ganzen Kondensatoren hier drauf könnte man ja verzichten, alles was Filterzeug ist,
dann taktet man die Karte halt ein bisschen runter, dann läuft die noch.
Ich sag, die geht noch, easy.
Wir könnten die auch bei eBay-Kleinanzeigen verkaufen.
Einfach, einfach, genau, leichte Gebrauchsspuren.
Like new, slightly used, eBay-Kleinanzeigen würde ich sagen.
Ich sag jetzt einfach mal, die geht noch.
Hüpft mal ab, man.
Also sagen wir mal so, wie ich die zuerst gesehen habe, würde ich sagen, nein, die geht
auf gar keinen Fall mehr.
Aber in Hinblick, dass das Video geht noch eine Weile und dass die irgendwie noch halbwegs
intakt aussieht.
Also mich würde nicht wundern, wenn sie noch geht.
Da muss halt ein neuer Lüfter drauf, ne?
Das sieht noch in Ordnung aus.
Sieht tatsächlich auch nicht so wild aus.
Also der Bereich hier hinten, der sieht echt ganz gut aus, würde ich sagen.
Ja, jetzt haben wir noch die Platte hier runter.
Hier vorne ist ein bisschen kritisch, hier war es bestimmt sehr warm, aber das hier sieht
alles tatsächlich noch ganz gut aus.
So, mittlerweile wieder bei mir zu Hause, ich hab jetzt die Grafikkarte.
Erinnert sich noch einer, weil es gerade jemand im Chat schreibt, erinnert sich noch einer
an den Xbox Fix, an den Xbox 360 Fix, die Xbox in den Ofen legen oder noch besser Handtuch,
Handtuch drumherum, Handtuch drumherum und zwei Stunden laufen lassen.
Hätte ich vielleicht doch L nehmen sollen, naja, okay, wird funktionieren.
Auf jeden Fall die Grafikkarte, soweit es geht, demontiert, also die Slotblende noch
weggemacht.
Jetzt wird erstmal geputzt.
Wir machen die jetzt erstmal so basic mäßig, so ein bisschen sauber.
Deswegen habe ich mir noch so eine Kiste besorgt, da ist schon ein Spüli ein bisschen
drin.
Ja, die Xbox 360, die hatte doch diesen Red Ring of Death Fehler, da gab es die unterschiedlichen
Fix, das mit dem Föhn, mit dem Tuch, mit dem Ofen.
Und dann machen wir die Karte erstmal so grundsätzlich so ein bisschen sauberer, bevor wir jetzt
da irgendwie mit krassen Reinigungsmitteln rangehen, weil da jetzt eben noch viele Rückstände
von der Verbrennung so Kram überall draufhängt auf diesem Teil.
Das versuchen wir jetzt erstmal abzumachen, bevor wir dann irgendwie...
Gut, da müssen wir jetzt ja nicht zugucken.
Also ich hoffe, er zeigt uns jetzt nicht, wie die Grafikkarte komplett wascht.
Also gerade hier vorne so ein Display, da riecht es auf jeden Fall immer extremst krass.
Also der PC war schon...
Aber ich glaube auch, dass die noch funktioniert, irgendwie habe ich so ein Gefühl, die geht
noch.
Okay, dann fangen wir jetzt mal an, die sauber zu machen.
Erstmal Zahnbürste holen.
Zahnbürste ist für sowas immer gut, oder Pinsel, Zahnbürste ist auch immer gut.
Okay, wir kriegen jetzt wirklich gezeigt, wie die Grafikkarte gewaschen wird.
Der Slot hier unten, ist da was abgegangen?
Dann ist RIP.
Also wenn die Slot-Kontakte weg sind, ist RIP.
Ach Moment, der Slot ist ja da unten.
Das da oben ist ja nur das SLI, das ist ja nur das SLI, ich habe mich total verguckt.
Ich bin gespannt.
SLI E, useless Kram.
Erster Waschgang ist durch, es bringt auf jeden Fall was, also gerade auf der Rückseite sieht
es echt nicht so schlecht aus, schlimmster Bereich ist nach wie vor hier vorne, gerade
was so den Bereich von Displayport und HDMI Adapter betrifft, da ist schon echt noch
krass viel Schlonser da unten hängt.
Aber die Sache ist die, die sind alle nicht verbogen, die Anschlüsse sehen so aus, als
gehen sie potenziell noch.
Hier oben noch, hier oben, jetzt machen wir noch mal einen zweiten, ich sag mal normalen
Waschgang mit Schleimwassel.
Aber Hauptsache das Logo ist drauf.
Und dann wahrscheinlich noch mal einen krassen Reiniger und dann schauen wir mal wie es aussieht.
Was mir auch so ein bisschen Sorgen macht ist der Bereich hier, man sieht die Kabel, die
ist ja schon ein bisschen verbogen von der Hitze, Platinen halten aber sehr viel aus,
also ich hoffe das es keinen permanenten Schaden zur Folge hat.
Uah, sag mal mal so, die Kondensatoren stört das jetzt auch nicht ob die dreckig sind oder
nicht.
Wer macht das nicht gerne auf der Grafikkarte mit dem Pinsel ein bisschen rumkratzen.
Wow!
Das sieht relativ gut aus das Ding.
Alleine das einfache Reinigen muss man sagen hat schon echt was gebracht, wir werden gleich
dann natürlich noch...
Direkt auf Viber kleiner zeigen das Ding.
Erstmal der Riechtest, alles klar, der Bauer hat mittlerweile so viel Erfahrung, der kann
anhand des Geruchs der Grafikkarte feststellen, auf wieviel Megahertz übertaktbar ist oder
nicht.
Das ist noch ein bisschen toasty, ja, aber es ist ein bisschen waschbenzin und schauen
wir mal ob wir damit noch ein paar Rest abgelöst bekommen, ich bin so gespannt ob die Karte
funktioniert, alle sagen nein, ich denke ja.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie in so alten Filmen so irgendwelche Pferdenleser, die dann durch
den Busch robben und erstmal so auf den Boden greifen und dran riechen und sagen aha, vor
zwei Tagen sind sie vorbeigekommen, so macht er das mit der Grafikkarte, wird dran gerochen
und ah, 1528 Megahertz, und wenn er richtig gut drauf ist, dann sagt er dir auch bei welcher
Spannung.
Ich habe jetzt schon mal das Setup aufgebaut, natürlich ein Riserkabel, das macht es einfacher
die Grafikkarte zu testen, die liegt schon hier.
Was ist das denn jetzt eigentlich für eine, haben wir das mittlerweile erfahren?
Oh, eine Runde Durchgangstesten?
Ich glaube das passt so.
Wir checken jetzt einfach mal schnell ob die Basics passen, also einfach mal so zwischen
12 Volt und Masse, einfach mal kurz Input checken hier, wie das hier aussieht, ich weiß
nicht ob das die richtige Seite ist oder ob die sowieso verbunden ist, aber das sieht
schon mal ganz gut aus, es ist einfach 3,7 Kiloohm, also da weiß man gibt es schon mal
nicht direkt einen Kurzschuss zwischen 12 Volt und Ground, dann können wir auf der Rückseite
mal noch schnell, also wenn es beept ist es in der Regel schlecht, oder je nachdem wie
das eingestellt ist das Ding.
Etwas größeren SMDs beim RAM, mal checken, da müssten wir so wahrscheinlich zwischen
20 und 50 Ohm vielleicht, 20 Ohm, sieht ganz gut aus, GPU ist ja immer extrem niedrig
ohmig, also ich weiß auch wenn jetzt wieder viele Leute ausrasten würden und mir erzählen
würden, man kann das so nicht messen, aber man kann das so messen.
Das ist der Unterschied zwischen Theorie und Praxis, ja die Messungen sacken zwar, aber
warum nicht?
Ja, GPU ist immer schwierig, ja 0,1 Ohm besser als 0 Ohm, also zumindest mal so auf den ersten
Blick sieht das ganz ordentlich aus, das heißt wir schließen jetzt mal an.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt, ich sag euch, das geht auch, jawoll, ja was sonst, ja was sonst,
abgefackele Grafiker erstmal flüssig Stickstoff kühlen, ja zu booten ist natürlich das allerwichtigste
erstmal ein bisschen Stickstoff drauf machen.
So, Netzteil an, schonmal gar nicht so schlecht, also Standby Power hat einigermaßen funktioniert,
jetzt packen wir das mal da drauf, ich halte das mal so ein bisschen fest, oder, der macht
wahrscheinlich nichts rein, oder, der macht wahrscheinlich einfach nur, dass da ein ordentlicher
Metallblock drauf ist, das ist ein bisschen schwierig, Displayport habe ich jetzt mal
den hier probiert, der vordere ist auf jeden Fall beschädigt, der wird es nicht machen,
HDMI müsste man schauen, der ist extrem verdreckt, also ich habe die Hoffnung auf diese zwei
Displayports, aber schauen wir jetzt mal was passiert.
Da ist was, da ist was, da ist was, also er hat irgendwas erkannt, geht, geht, easy, easy,
der geht ins Wind aus, die Karte funktioniert, man sieht ja an der Auflösung auch schon,
dass er sogar schon den Display-Treiber installiert hat, die Karte funktioniert, das war übrigens
mal eine MSI 2070 Super, das habe ich auf Info ausgelesen, viele werden sich jetzt vielleicht
auch fragen, wie kann es sein, dass so eine Karte so etwas überlebt, aber, erstmal eBay
klein anzeigen, was letzter Preis, es muss ja das Lot schmelzen, also weit über 200
Grad Celsius, je nach Lot natürlich, und zwar auch nur für eine kurze Temperatur, aber
man konnte eben sehen, dadurch, dass keine Teile abgefallen sind, war es nicht in diesem
Bereich, war vielleicht bei 150 Grad Celsius, und solange so eine Karte nicht aktiv ist,
ist das erstmal nicht so wirklich ein Problem, weil Silicium wird irgendwann vom Halbleiter
zum Leiter, aber eben nur bei einer sehr hohen Temperatur, 140, 130 Grad Celsius ist vom
exakten Silicium-Typ abhängig und wenn das zum Leiter wird, dann brennt so eine GPU natürlich
sofort durch, aber eben nur wenn sie aktiv ist, wenn sowas aus ist wie in dem Fall, ist
es weniger ein Problem, sehr cool, sehr sehr cool, dass die Karte funktioniert, da sieht
man nochmal was Hardware, leichte Gebrauchsspuren und ab auf eBay klein anzeigen, tatsächlich
alles aushalten kann, ja jetzt muss ich das aber langsam mal ausmachen, weil der Flüssigstückstoffkühler
wird so lang der Kram noch geabbrecht, ich habe ja leider keinen Originalkühler mehr,
vielleicht finde ich irgendwo einen Wasserkühler, ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich mir da gerade
mache, aber war sehr sehr beeindruckend zu sehen, jetzt das Gegenteil, erst nochmal Flüssigstückstoff
und übertakken, wir wissen ja, Hitze hält sich gut aus, alles klar, bis nächstes Mal,
easy.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an, your WiFi sucks, 5 Tipps fürs, ok, das
gucken wir uns jetzt an, der Channel ist übrigens ziemlich gut, was Heimautomatisierung angeht
und Controllerkram und sowas, mal gucken, ich könnte mir vorstellen, er empfiehlt Dinge,
die mir nicht gefallen, ich weiß, dass der riesen Fan ist von irgendwelchen Google Mesh
WiFi Geräten, das ist eher nicht so meins, laut genug, bisschen lauter kann man mal, also
das aller aller einfachste, dürfte immer noch sein, mal gucken, welche Frequenzen von
den Nachbarn nicht so sehr belegt sind und dann sein WLAN darauf legen, das dürfte immer
noch das einfachste und Easiest zu sein, was jeder machen kann.
In some regards, WiFi is extremely complicated, but the most common problems are caused by
two things that are relatively simple to understand, called attenuation and interference.
WiFi consists of different frequencies of radio waves, and although radio waves are different
than sound waves, a simple analogy can be made between the two to teach you why your
WiFi sucks.
Imagine you're in a large ballroom and you want to talk to a person all the way on the
other side of the room.
If the room is empty, the only limitations would be the volume of your voices and the
sensitivity of your ears.
Let's say that one person can't talk very loud and they also have really bad hearing.
If the other person has great hearing and a loud voice, the conversation can still happen,
but if not, there's going to be a lot of what did you say and can you repeat that going
on, which will decrease the rate of your overall conversation.
WiFi-Devices have the same two important characteristics.
They have transmit power, or how loud they can talk, and they have antenna gain, or how
well they can listen.
In most cases, the majority of the data is going to flow from the access point to the
device, so that's what we're going to look at first.
This video is sponsored by Gosund, manufacturers of quality smart home basics like...
Gosund!
Lul!
Keck wait!
Erinnert sich noch einer daran, wo ich versucht habe die Gosund-Steckdose aufzubekommen
und sie dann auseinandergerissen habe aus Versehen.
Ich zeige euch jetzt nicht den Clip, die dabei waren, die China-Steckdose, wo ich zu blöd
war die Schraube zu finden, wo ich sie dann auseinandergerissen habe.
Live on stream, ja.
Wifi-Plugsockets, Lightbulbs und LED-Strips.
Genau, und am Ende hat es sich herausgestellt, man kann sie sogar OTA-Flashen, die mich jetzt
gar nicht aufmachen müssen.
Findet ihr, ich finde dieses Kokona-Steckdosen, die sehen immer aus wie so ein Z-Smiley,
oder?
Findet ihr nicht auch?
Also es hat...
Es sieht übelst...
Pippe-Hands-Steckdose aus, ne?
Gosund.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Ein LED, das ist aber unter seinem Niveau.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein Video, was ihm Gosund geschickt hat.
Die LED-Strips um den Ständer wickeln, das ist aber echt unter seinem Niveau.
Ich glaube, das haben ihm die Chinesen geschickt, weil das ist so eine typische China-Installation.
Weiß einer, ob man über AT-Commands MQTT-Daten senden kann?
Was sind denn AT-Commands?
Hä?
Das muss ich jetzt nicht so genau verstehen.
Meinst du Telefon?
SmartThings, das ist Paints-Champ.
Bringst dich, ich mach nächste Woche eine Runde Hetzner-Sellout-Video wieder.
Wird Zeit.
Oh, jetzt wird's Big-Blank, komm, ich will wissen, wie man Wi-Fi besser machen kann.
Das ist nicht verkehrt, ja, einfach messen, wie gut man was empfängt, ja, aber was mach
ich denn jetzt, was mach ich denn jetzt, um es besser zu machen?
What the fuck?
Was muss ich denn jetzt machen, dass es besser wird?
Move your devices, no shit, wenn mein Empfang zu schlecht liegt, weil das Ding weit zu weit
weg ist, soll ich es bewegen, dass es näher dran ist, nein, da wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen.
Ich hab ne Aufmerksamkeitsspanne von zwei Sekunden, nee, aber ihr habt die, deswegen
spül ich das vor.
Ja, aber sag mal so, also den Kram zu moveen, da ist ja, glaub ich schon jeder Kacktub drauf
gekommen.
Okay, wir gehen einfach vor, choose your frequency, genau, exakt, das ist das, was ich am Anfang
gesagt hab, das kann man wirklich easy machen, so, nächster Tipp, nächster Tipp, das meinte
ich übrigens mit Channel, nächste Tipp, nächste Tipp, eliminate other wifi networks, das heißt,
ich muss erstmal den Router abreißen beim Nachbar, perfekt, sehr gute Idee, erst mal
beim Nachbar einbrechen und nichts machen, außer den Exitpoint abreißen, nee, okay,
das Video ist diesmal nicht so, nicht so, nicht so spannend, nicht so, wir gucken uns
lieber an Pocket EMP versus Padlock, easy, mein Chrome ist blau, weil es ein Chromium
ist und kein Chromium, ich hab aber auch nur für den Fall, ich hab auch noch einen normalen
Chromium, ah, Sellout, macht der Knife Sellout, what, was sonst, Low Power EMP Generator,
ich mein sowas sollte man schon mal daheim haben, oder, also das ist schon wichtig, dass
man so einen EMP Generator daheim hat, oh, MonkaS, das Geräusch, hört schon wie ein
Taser, okay, das war wirklich easy, easy as fuck, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
easy, easy, ja, siehste, man braucht einfach, ist in Deutschland, ist in Deutschland jetzt
schon mal wieder nicht erlaubt, weil du es mit einer Hand aufmachen kannst, aber so easy
kann es sein, man braucht einfach einen Pocket EMP, also Leute, jetzt weiß ich schon, was
das nächste ist, was wir basteln, wir basteln so einen Pocket EMP, ich weiß zwar nicht
wozu, aber so einen Pocket EMP kann man schon mal gebrauchen, kann man mit dem EMP dann
auch das Wi-Fi vom Nachbarn killen, ja, er hier, er hier, der hat schon teilweise ganz
gute Videos, aber er hier ist Meister, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an, er ist Meister,
seine Videos, die eigentlich vielleicht 30 Sekunden Aussagekraft haben, auf 20 Minuten
zu strecken, da ist er wirklich richtig, richtig gut drin, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an,
neue Zollregel, das Resident Sleeper, übrigens das hier wollte ich mir, das wollte ich demnächst
mal im Stream, das wollte ich demnächst mal im Stream ausprobieren, ich zeige euch das
mal kurz, ich habe mir das Video schon angeguckt, ich habe mir nämlich selbst einen Pack bestellt
bei Amazon, ESP32CAM Module, das hier, sowas in der Richtung habe ich mir bestellt, und
damit, was ist das, und damit kann man jetzt wohl mit der passenden Firmware Zählerstände
auslesen, per optischer Erkennung, ich zeige euch das mal, ich muss ein bisschen vorspulen,
so, also Firmware, das ist alles langweilig, genau, so ein Teil habe ich mir gekauft mit
Kamera dabei, und das ist alles nicht so interessant, der löst nur ein paar LEDs dran, das ist
auch nicht so, hier wird es interessant, guck mal, guck mal, der hat hier seinen Wasserzähler,
mit Infrarot-LED geht das auch, wenn man den Infrarot-Filter entfernt von der Kamera,
und der hat den Wasserzähler, und mit der passenden Firmware kannst du quasi Bilderkennung
machen, AI-Blockchain, agil geschützt natürlich, und hier oben hat er seinen Strom, kannst
du direkt mit dem ESP32 hier OCR-Bilderkennung, AI-Big-Brain-Bilderkennung machen und das
auslesen, und nicht nur Zählerstände, sondern auch analoge Anzeigen geht auch, ja, das braucht
man wahrscheinlich bei meinem Keller nicht, so, aber was viel interessanter ist, ist der
Einrichtungsprozess, die haben nämlich ein komplettes Webinterface gebaut, um das Ganze
einzurechnen, wozu das Ganze, naja, dass du zum Beispiel weißt, was du für einen Stromverbrauch
hast, dass du ohne in den Keller zu gehen deinen Dingszähler ablesen kannst, dass du zum Beispiel
an einer Heizung, wo du den Wasserdruck, den Druck siehst, der ab und zu mal sinnloserweise
fällt bei meiner Heizung, wo du an den Keller gehen musst und ein bisschen Wasser aufdrehen
musst, dass du es dann von oben auslesen kannst, ob du wieder in den Keller musst und so, das
hat schon seinen Anwendungszweck, ich zeig's euch mal auf GitHub, das ist interessanter
zu sehen, man kann nämlich, hier guck, man kann analoge Zähler auslesen, das ist sehr
praktisch, also man kann eben quasi sagen, wo befinden sich die Zahlen und da ist AI
technisch so schlau, dass der analoge Zählerständer auslesen kann, also der erkennt zum Beispiel,
dass das hier 5,8 ist, das finde ich ist eine coole Geschichte, also, das werde ich, das
probieren wir demnächst im Stream mal aus, ja, das ist gar nicht, ja, das kann man machen,
das kann man, also ich hab's aktuell so, ich hab an meinem Stromzähler was dran, ich habe
noch so ein Oldschool Stromzähler, da hab ich aktuell was dran, was diesen Ring der
durchläuft zählt, wie oft der durchläuft, digitale Druckmesssensoren kosten ja nix,
wie sieht sowas aus, schick mal, schick mal bitte einen Link, schick mal, würde mich
mal interessieren, das ist aber dann was, was man dazwischen schrauben muss, das muss
man dann quasi irgendwie ins Gerät, in das Rohr oder um das Rohr oder wie auch immer
oder zwischen Verbindungen von dem Rohr schrauben, das funktioniert nicht, würde ich nicht machen
und das funktioniert auch nicht, also es fällt sofort auf, was verarbeitet denn die Daten,
das kann zum Teil der ESP32 selbst machen und dann musst du halt gucken, wie du das
an deine Heimautomatisierung schickst, übrigens wisst ihr was ich mir überlegt hab, ich
wollte unbedingt mal so ein Video hier machen, Half-Life Cat, ich wollte mal so ein Video
mit Chico machen, also nicht sowas, ein Video wo ich Chico aufnehme und mach Half-Life
Sounds dabei, da gibt es jede Menge lustige Videos und ich hab ein paar bescheuerte Clips,
wo Chico sinnlos rum rennt, da könnte man wunderbare Sounds dabei machen, Peter, warum
Peter, ich hab ein Bild wie Chico auf dem Bett rum springt und irgendwie nicht checkt,
weil die ist feinmotorisch nicht die Schlauste, FIFA 22, Downgrade, ja wahrscheinlich dass
es auf der Switch läuft, der Bauer, der haut aber hier Videos raus, da ist die Katz, da
ist die Katz dicker geworden, Moment, ist seine Katz dicker geworden, ne das ist die
andere oder, hat er nicht zwei oder bringe ich es jetzt durcheinander, der passt so dick
aus wie meine, weil Chico ist auch nicht die dünnste, Designer Bike Logs, ok, so, dann
muss ich das noch mal kurz angucken, muss ich kurz Musik ausmachen, was soll denn ein
Design Log sein, ist das irgendwie ein Log, ist das ein Schloss, wo dann Adidas draufsteht
oder, was, warum, ok.
Das sollte als ein Sicherheitsgerät oder ein Fascheneckzesserie evaluiert werden.
Ich weiß, dass es etwas tut, das an allen Kosten auf dem Bike Rack gebraucht wird, und das ist Attraktivität.
Das sagt, dass das Kryptonite Evolution Lock nicht schlecht ist.
Wir haben einen ziemlich steilen 10mm Hexlink-Chain, der in einen integrierten Lock mit Disk-Detainer-Core fährt.
Also, schauen wir mal, wie lange es dauert, diesen zu öffnen.
Der wackelt jetzt dreimal dran und es ist offen oder sowas.
Mit den meisten Disk-Detainer-Cores starte ich, die Disks zu öffnen, so lang wie möglich.
Dann werde ich den Pick bekommen, den wir mit Bill und Bosni gemacht haben.
Jetzt holt er wieder seine Big-Brain-Tools raus, ja.
Finden wir Disk Nummer 2 und bekommen 2 Picks.
Okay, ein kleiner Klick aus 2.
Kein 3.
4 ist Binding, oder irgendwie sowas sagt er jetzt gleich.
Ich weiß ja immer noch nicht, was er eigentlich da sagt, aber...
Kein 4. 5 ist Binding.
5 ist Binding, 5 ist Binding, aha, aha, aha, 5 ist Binding.
6 ist Binding.
Klick aus 6.
7 fühlt sich an, dass es gesetzt ist.
Gehen wir zurück zum Anfang.
Kein 2. Es fühlt sich an, dass es gesetzt ist.
3 ist Binding jetzt.
Klick aus 3.
Und wir haben das geöffnet.
Okay, Leute.
Während die Farben und Branding ein wenig anders sind,
ist es immer noch ein ganz normales Kryptonite-Produkt mit all den Gutes und Böses,
das mit dem Produkt kommt.
Einer der guten Aspekte ist das Fakt, dass ihr spezielle Tools und Skills braucht,
um das non-destruktiv zu öffnen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, oder du brauchst eine ordentliche Schere.
Also Zange, nicht Schere, also was Großes.
Okay, das war's für heute.
Wenn ihr Fragen oder Kommentare habt, schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat, und wolltet ihr mehr von uns sehen,
dann abonniert es bitte.
Und wie immer, habt einen schönen Tag.
Danke.
Easy.
Ja, oder wahrscheinlich brauchst du nicht mal eine Flex.
Wahrscheinlich tut es auch, tut es auch was kleineres.
Irgend so ein Dremel mit dem passenden Aufsatz,
weil soll er nicht dick, wird die eigentliche Kette ja nicht sein.
Feuerwehrauto mit Hydraulikschere, das geht mit Sicherheit auch.
Also ich hab mit meinem, mit meinem Dremel und dem passenden Aufsatz
schon mal einen Wäscheständer durchgeschnitten.
Fragt mich jetzt nicht, warum ich sowas mache, aber das hat funktioniert.
Irgendwie so eine Metalltrennscheibe, Scheibe, Scheibe, sowas da braucht man.
Ja, so, so Dinger braucht man dafür.
Das wird dann reingeklipst und dann habe ich den Wäscheständer durchgeschnitten.
Easy.
Da habe ich zum ersten Mal gelernt, dass wenn man Metall schneidet, dass es Funken gibt.
Wer hätte auch an sowas denken können?
Kannst du eine Alternative zu den Gosun Smart Plugs empfehlen?
Nee, das kann man immer schlecht, weil man nicht weiß, was Flashbar ist und was nicht.
Das ist immer, das ändert sich wöchentlich.
Also ich würde prinzipiell nur die Dinger nehmen, die man flaschen kann.
Ansonsten, wenn du, wenn du ein bisschen mehr Geld ausgeben möchtest,
dann kann ich dir die Shelly-Dinger empfehlen.
Also die ganzen Shelly-Produkte kann man sich eigentlich alle geben.
Ist halt teurer als Viererpack China-Chinesen-Steckdosen.
Also für so einen Shelly-Dinger ist es halt teurer.
Also für so einen Shelly-Plug, zum Beispiel so ein schaltbares Ding hier oder sowas,
da bezahlst du wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung, 18 Euro oder sowas.
Was kostet so ein Shelly-Plug gerade?
Und für den gleichen Preis, ja 18 Euro,
für den gleichen Preis kriegst du schon Viererpack China-Steckdosen.
Und bei den China-Steckdosen musst du halt gucken, dass die flashbar sind.
Ja und es gibt auf Aliexpress welche, die sind flashbar.
Ja und es gibt auf Aliexpress welche direkt mit Tasmota,
aber Aliexpress ist gerade ein bisschen schwierig zu bestellen.
Die Chinesen brauchen gerade ein bisschen wahrscheinlich noch,
bis genug hergestellt ist und bis das mit dem Versand wieder alles funktioniert.
Ja.
Ist der Frasher eigentlich on?
Ai Frizi.
Zeigst mal her.
Kein Frasher am Start.
Er mit seinen Web-Mobile-Games wieder.
Traut man vorgeflashten das Tasmota-Steckdosen von Aliexpress?
Ehrlich gesagt, ne, ich nicht.
Deswegen ist das auch was, was ich mir nie bestellt hab.
Ich mein, der Vorteil davon ist, du kannst, wenn da wirklich Tasmota drauf ist,
du kannst es halt relativ einfach selbst flashen.
Aber du hast halt keine Ahnung, was da sonst noch so.
Aber es macht auf jeden Fall den normalen Flash-Vorgang einfacher.
Leute, ich glaube, ich geh jetzt was essen.
Ich hab übelst Hunger.
Und vielleicht, vielleicht machen wir heute Abend sogar noch die Geschichte
mit der ESP32-CAM und AI-Detection.
Mal gucken, ob's mir danach ist.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich muss mir heute noch Sellout, ich muss Sellout-Video aufnehmen
und muss mir noch Themen überlegen.
Also ich hab mir, ich hab mir jetzt schon, also ich hab mir schon überlegt.
Ich mach ein Stream nächste Woche, wo wir uns nochmal Linux-Surfer einrichten
für Noobs angucken.
Hetzner Sellout Stream.
Und ich mach nächste Woche ein Azubi, Top 10 Azubi-Tipps-Video.
Ich hab mir schon die letzten Monate über, das ist tatsächlich gar kein Schnellschuss-Video oder so.
Ich hab mir schon die letzten Monate immer mal wieder was aufgeschrieben,
wenn mir was eingefallen ist, was man als guten Tipp geben könnte.
Zum Beispiel nicht so sehr auf Berufsschule und Betrieb verlassen, dass man was lernt.
Oder der IHK prinzipiell erstmal nix glauben und Abschlussprüfungen üben und sowas.
Und da ist einer der Punkte drin, dass ich sag, hey, man muss selbst ein bisschen gucken,
was man kann und was man lernt.
Und dazu bietet es sich natürlich auch super an, sich mal einen virtuellen Server zu kaufen
und ein bisschen rumzuprobieren.
Und wer das machen will, kann das mit meinem 20-Euro-Startguthaben machen.
Irgendwie sowas werde ich das einbauen.
Und danach nochmal den gesponserten Stream.
Also ich werde es wahrscheinlich jetzt so machen, zwei gesponserte Streams im Monat
und ein gesponsertes Video im Monat.
So, werden wir das jetzt wahrscheinlich machen.
Das heißt, es wird nicht zu viel und es passt immer ganz gut zum Thema.
Ich glaube, da haben alle was von.
Du kannst dir immer, immer die Wots angucken.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass ich es heute mache.
Hetzer Serverbörse zeige ich nicht, weil ich explizit, es ist ja nicht komplett Hetzer,
ich habe nur Hetzer Cloud.
Also ich kriege nur, ich werde nur bezahlt für Werbung für Hetzer Cloud, nicht für
Hetzer Serverbörse.
Also mache ich auch nur Cloud.
Das ist eine super Geschichte generell.
Also man kann sich bei Hetzer nicht beschweren.
Es hat sich letztens einer beschwert in den Kommentaren bei mir.
Er hat gesagt, hier, was hätte ich da für eine Scheiße empfohlen.
Er hat jetzt nicht bezahlt und sie haben ihm das Konto geschlossen.
Und dann hat er gesagt, er hat jetzt nicht bezahlt und sie haben ihm das Konto geschlossen.
Wo ich mir da immer denke, ja gut, wenn man sich neu registriert und dann einfach 14 Tage
nicht bezahlt, dann musst du dich nicht wundern, wenn es einem das Konto schließt.
Ich meine, wenn man da jetzt schon zwei Jahre dabei ist und mal ein bisschen später überweist
oder Paypal macht, ist okay.
Aber wenn man jetzt komplett neu registriert ist mit Gratisguthaben, braucht das auf und
bezahlt dann 14 Tage nicht, dann weiß ich, da muss man sich nicht wundern, wenn einem
das Konto, Konto geschlossen.
Wobei, es ist so, dass man sich nicht wundern muss.
Da muss man sich nicht wundern, wenn einem das Konto, Konto geschlossen.
Wobei, es wurde ihm ja noch nicht mal das Konto geschlossen.
Es wurden ihm einfach alle Server gelöscht.
Das finde ich aber auch in Ordnung.
Ja.
Ja, du kriegst eine Abmahnung, genau.
Dazu hat er nichts geschrieben.
Wahrscheinlich hat er die auch gekriegt.
Es ist aber nicht mein Problem, aber ganz ehrlich, wenn du 14 Tage nicht bezahlst, musst
du dich nicht wundern, dass du deinen Server ausgeschaltet kriegst.
Vor allem, wenn es ein neuer Account ist mit Gratisguthaben.
Und du nicht weißt, ob jemals Geld kommt.
Wenn man da jetzt schon eine Weile dabei ist und immer bezahlt hat und dann mal irgendwie
im Urlaub ist oder so, dann verstehe ich es ja.
Dann schalten die das, dann werden sie ja auch den Account nicht einfach schließen.
Aber wenn es halt die erste Zahlung überhaupt ist mit Gratisguthaben, dann kann ich schon
verstehen, dass man da ein bisschen genauer drauf guckt.
Ja, also da verstehe ich auch nicht, wie, da muss man halt den Kran bezahlen.
Das kann ja nicht so schwierig sein.
Muss man sich ja nicht, muss man sich ja nicht beschweren.
Ich habe auch schon einmal vergessen zu bezahlen.
Man kann ja leider nicht im Voraus bezahlen.
Also nicht per Paypal, nur per Überweisung.
Wenn man im Voraus bezahlen könnte, hätte ich, hätte ich, hätte ich da schon irgendwie
mal 500 Euro oder so aufgeladen, dass ich jetzt erst mal wieder ein Jahr nicht bezahlen
muss.
Aber nope, no pass.
Das weiß ich nicht, ich bezahle immer ein paar Paypal.
Ich glaube, das ist halt, die sehen das halt ein bisschen kritisch, wenn du dich angemeldet
hast mit Gratisguthaben und das erste Mal, wo du Geld bezahlen musstest, einfach 14 Tage
nicht bezahlst.
Aber insgesamt kann ich wirklich da nichts Schlechtes sagen.
Ich hatte schon bei der Server Börse Kisten, ich hatte schon bei Hetzner Cloud Kisten.
Ich konnte mich da, konnte mich da nie beschweren.
Ich habe ja versucht auf der Arbeit den Leuten auch schon ein bisschen Hetzner schmackhaft
zu machen, weil die ja Probleme gerade was Storage und sowas angeht bei Azure haben.
Wobei da wird, da will keiner drauf eingehen.
Ich habe gesagt, hey, ich kann euch auch ein 20 Euro Startguthaben Gutschein geben.
Hat aber keinen geschockt.
Gut, was ist ein 20 Euro Startguthaben bei teilweise 80.000, 80.000 Euro im Monat
Storage Kosten bei Azure.
Aber die Azure Storage Preise sind eh der Witz, absolut lächerlich.
80.000 Euro im Monat, die haben sie nicht mal.
Das ist sicherlich auch nicht schlecht.
Hey Max, wie war eigentlich dein Werdegang nach deiner Ausbildung zum Dev?
Ich habe keine Ausbildung zum DevOps gemacht.
Ich habe eine Ausbildung Fachinformatik und Systemintegration gemacht.
Ach du meinst, wie der Werdegang von der Ausbildung bis zu war.
Ach so, ja, ja, ja.
Und fühle mich richtig unqualifiziert.
Ich bin am überlegen nicht.
Das musst du wissen.
Das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Das Wichtigste ist, aber ich glaube nicht, dass dich ein Informatik Studium jetzt in
der Reihen Technik kompetenter macht.
Was ein Informatik Studium macht, ist, dass du von den Grundlagen und den
Hintergründen mehr Ahnung hast.
Du wirst da jetzt nichts lernen im großen Umfang, was dir jetzt direkt in dem Job,
wo du dich unqualifiziert fühlst, mehr Qualifizierung geben wird.
Du bist dann theoretisch deutlich besser, hast viel mehr Ahnung, wie das alles von
den Hintergründen her funktioniert.
Du kannst auch beispielsweise mal ausrechnen, wie lang läuft irgendwas oder kannst
vielleicht auch ein bisschen Big Brain Mathe Zeug machen.
Aber wenn du beispielsweise sagst, du hast eine Physi-Ausbildung gemacht, hast
jetzt keine Ahnung, dann wird das Studium dir da auch nicht viel bringen.
Dann ist das Einzige, was du machen kannst und das, was man eigentlich auch nur
jedem empfehlen kann, während der Ausbildung zu machen, ist, sich erstens
anzugucken, was für ein Bereich ist es, der mir gefällt, und sich selbst in
diesem Bereich fortbilden.
Man kann sich nicht darauf verlassen, dass man in der Berufsschule was beigebracht
kriegt, und man kann sich je nach Betrieb auch nicht darauf verlassen, dass man
im Betrieb was beigebracht kriegt.
Und wenn du einen Bereich gefunden hast, der dich interessiert, sagen wir jetzt
mal Virtualisierung zum Beispiel oder ganz grob Linux-Sachen, irgendwie
irgendwelche Programmiergeschichten oder was auch immer, dann musst du dich
privat, und da kommt man eh früher oder später nicht drumherum, muss dich privat
mit den Themen beschäftigen.
Ja, also, man kann im Prinzip nur was lernen, wenn man auch wirklich lernt.
Ist Hetzer denn besser, als das Ding Bare Metal zu Hause zu haben?
Das kommt drauf an.
Wenn du von außen darauf zugreifen willst, auf jeden Fall, also je nachdem,
was es ist, wenn du jetzt eine private Webseite hast, wenn du da jetzt deine
private Nextcloud hast, dann ist ein VPN das bessere.
Es kommt auf den Service an, was du benutzen willst.
Ja, genau, da lernst du ja im Prinzip nichts.
Ach, nice, dann hast du es endlich geschafft, Pog.
Was hast du gemacht, das habe ich glaube ich schon mal gefragt, was hast du für
ein Abschlussprojekt gemacht?
Es sind ja jetzt gerade Prüfungen, das waren ja gerade Prüfungen.
Also ich hatte, ah, MDM, stimmt, ja genau.
Ich habe eben glaube auch Ende Juli meine Abschlussprüfung gemacht.
Weißt du das schon gar nicht, ich bin ja schon ewig, ewig her.
Das ist da, wo sie mich angerufen haben, dass ich durchgefallen bin, bevor ich die
Prüfung hatte, habe ich ja mal ein Video erzählt.
Also die Ausbindung habe ich 2007 gemacht.
Also ich schon ein bisschen.
So Leute, ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Pepo Fett.
Wir sehen uns, bis zum nächsten Stream.
See you, machts gut.